اغلب الناس عندهم مشكله بالرقبه لما تاخذ
تاريخهم فوق الخمسين بالمئه منهم يذكر انه
صار في حدث نفسي او استماعي او على مستوى
الوظيفه قوي من بعدها بلشت تطلع الام
الرقبه سيده
انتقلت من المدينه الى مدينه تمام او
عندها اسف الام رقبه وجت لما خذينا
التاريخ لقينا ان تزوجت قبل الالم تمام
وعلاقتها الزوجيه زينه وكل شيء الى
المدينه الجديده والمدينه الجديده غريبه
عليها وكانت خايفه انها تترك اهلها وبلشت
المشكله
اهلا هذا فنجان من ثمانيه وانا عبد الرحمن
ابو مالح كيف تعيش بدون الام جسديه حياتنا
اليوم ليست كما عاشها اجدادنا ابدا تخيل
يوم انك
عشان تتحرك تدفع فلوس وتشترك في نادي
رياضي بينما كان هذا النشاط والحركه جزء
من حياه الانسان الطبيعيه مع الجلسه
الطويله الجلسه على الجوال والحركه
المحدوده كيف ممكن
نقدر نعيش بصحه حركيه افضل كيف نقي انفسنا
من مشاكل الظهر الركبه القدم الرقبه
وغيرها هل فيها جلسه
صحيحه تقي من هذه المشاكل عند الكبر
فالحلقه مع ضيفي امير الدعافر واخصائي
علاج حركي مهتم بالصحه الحركيه للانسان من
الحركه حتى التنفس
فقد تكون
هناك مشاكل والام في جسمنا حلها لا يتطلب
وجود طبيب وانما
ضبط اليه التنفس عندك
قبل ان نبدا عندي ايمان بان جزء كبير من
سعاده الانسان مرتبط برضاه عن حياته وجزء
كبير من هذا الرضا يعتمد على نمط حياته
اليوميه اللي ينعكس اثره على صحته وعلاقته
وعمله عشان كذا اطلقنا في ثمانيه نشره
بريديه جديده وهي نشرت نمط يكتبها لك
الصديق العزيز البراء العهدي المتخصص في
تصميم نمط الحياه اشترك في النشره وانتظر
العدد الاول السبت المقبل رابط الاشتراك
في وصف هذه الحلقه
اما الان لنبدا
الى ذكر فيه
ما ادري والله وين سمعته يعني
في بودكاست ما كانوا يقولون ان
ان الانسان اليوم يلبس الجزمه وهو مفترض
انه ما يلبس يعني لم يخلق للمستجمه وشيء
يمسك رجله طول الوقت كانت نصيحه لطلع فيها
نهائي يعني كانت كلهم دكاتره وباحثين في
القدم يعني
انك حاول انك تكون حافي ما
استطعتم
اتذكرها الحين ان قدم زي اليد فيها كل
يعني تقدر تشوفها كل شيء تقدر تسوي بيدك
اللهم انه بس احنا ما نمررها الى حد ما
يعني الابهام عندك ابهام في القدم بس انت
لاحظت اني انا اقدر اسوي كل الحركه هذه بس
رجولي
تقدر مع الوقت يعني تشوف الناس سبحان الله
اللي مبتوره ايده شوفوا شلون استخدم قدمه
الشوكه عادي عنده يلبس نفسه بقدمه عادي
طبيعي يعني تشوف بعد على تعليقك على موضوع
القدم انما حضارات او خلينا نقول القبائل
الحين في افريقيا مثلا المسايا يلبسون بس
يلا جوتي نفس مفهومنا الحالي الوصول مثل
نعال
حتى في قبيله في المكسيك اسمها هل ترى
هماره هذه معروفه بان من نقطه الف نقطه
يروحونها ركض القبيله اللي تركض هذا اسمها
متعودين نركض حافي او جدا مرمل يعني شيء
جدا خفيف
يرسل البقاله
ليش بلشت سالفه الركض وهم مسلمين اي احد
هجم عليهم قام اركبه فهمت
دخلوهم هذا لانه يركض وايد
هذا يروح عشرين ثلاثين اربعين كيلو ما
عنده مشكله باليوم
وتغذيته على ماي شعير فقط
فلما حطوهم جواتي لا صار عندهم اصابات
قدموا متعوده مو متعوده ابدا فكله على
التعود كله على انت تعطي قدمك البيئه اللي
تبيها وتحتاجها فالحين ممكن هذا قلت حق
شخص روح اركض حافي اصابه على طول مو متعود
قدمها ضعيفه تحتاج شويه او بطانه على اساس
يقدر يستمر
فاهم من ناحيه والله علماء انه والله انت
تستخدم الحذاء ولا لا في في خلاف على ذلك
يعني دائما يقول لك لا تسوي نقله فجاه
تروح من حذاء والله في خمسه سته الى صفر
راح تادي نفسك لان التغيير المفاجئ في اي
شيء راح يؤدي الى الى مشاكل او اصابه
[موسيقى]
يعني تقبل والله خل نقول فاشن او ازياء
شوي شوي ان شاء الله يصير معنا في قبل
نبدا الحلقه
نبحث
في الاعداد
ان كان في تحدي
يعني يعني كنقول دارس هندسه صح فيعني يعني
فصارخ قلق وخوف انه نقدم احد يعني ما
عندها خلفيه طبيه ايه
طبيب ما عنده شيء يخليه يتكلم فهل يعني
كثير الكل يمدح يعني بس زين اهم شيء بس شو
النقله يعني شو النقله وكيف هل عادي انه
الواحد يكون مدارس يقدم كل هذا طبعا هل
واحد عادي يكون دارس كمبيوتر ساينس ويقدم
بودكاست
[ضحك]
شوف ارتباط الهندسه بالحركه ارتباط جدا
عميق يعني في تخصص كامل اسمه
اللي هو حيوي ومكانك الميكانيكيه الحركه
فالصراحه لقيت كميه الهندسه خاصه ماده
المهندسين اكيد يعرفون اسماء ستاتكس اللي
هي المبنى والسترس اللي عليها والضغط اللي
عليه والدايناميكس اللي هي حركه الاشياء
من ناحيه او قوه او زوايا موجوده في
الحركه فتقيس مثلا انا شفت جمال الحركه
والهندسه في الحركه ما بين علاقه مثلا
الورك مع الركبه مع القدم
وابدات الحمد لله في في فهمها اسرع من
غيري فحتى لما اروح كورسات يكون معانا
طبعا اخصائي ناش طبيعي دكاتره وغيره اشوف
استقبال المعلومه اسرع وطبعا هذه البدايه
كانت خل نقول عن تجربه شخصيه انا مريت فيه
اصابات
وما لقيت ما لقيت حل يعني الحلول
التقليديه ما جابت اي نتيجه بس لما اتجهت
الى مدارس مؤسسينها مهندسين او مصممه
ازياء او مدرسين انجليزي هذا لي ثلاثه من
المدرسين هم ملهمني لقيت فرق وايد كبير
على قدمي على كتفي على تنفسه على على كل
شيء
الشغف ياخذ الشخص الى الاتجاه اللي يبيه
وطبعا ما هو انا ما قاعد اقول اي شيء من
عندي وهو ماخذ اسس من مدارس تسمح لي غير
المتخصصين او عندهم خلفيه طبيه انه
يمارسون العلاج الحركي
له علاقه بصحه الانسان والطب
فهذه المكان ما يسمح بالشغف يعني عاده يجب
انك تكون يعني ماخذ الاشياء اللي الناس
متعوده عليها انك تدخل في المجال
الاكاديمي كما هو
فهل
في اطباء يقولوا لك انه تسوي خطا اكيد
اكيد بشرتك عليهم يعني في رد او في خلينا
نقول
رفض من الاطباء وفي قبول من اخصائي العلاج
طبيعي يعني في وايد اخصائي طبيعي يرسلون
مرضعهم لي لان احنا بالنهايه في خل نقول
مزيج ما بين العلاج وما بين التدريب وانا
كل اللي قاعد اسوي احاول اوازن الجسم مثل
ما اقدر وهذا العامل الهندسي
طبعا في شغلات خارجه عن او او فوق مستواي
التعليمي فوق خلينا نقول تخصصي هذه طبعا
ارجع الى اخصائي او دكتور او او ايا كان
لما تقول الخصائح وش تقصد فيها
نظره تجمع عده مدارس وهي استخدام الحركه
او يسمونه بعد
علوم الحركه وانتقال الانسان من نقطه الف
الى الباء وحركه المفاصل في اني اعالج
الانسان او ارد الاتزان الى جسمه فهو ما
هي مدرسه واحده هي مسمى عام لعده مدارس
معنيه في اني انا شلون اذا شخص فقد
او الاتزان في الورك القدم في اسفل الظهر
شلون اقدر اعيد لهذا التوازن مع الوقت
اي جزء من العلاج طبيعي يعني تشوف فوائد
حركه حيويه
يكونون اخصائي علاج طبيعي وفي لا مثلا
دارسين سبورت ساينس او علم علم الرياضه او
دارسين هندسه او دارسين ايا كان ايا كان
علاج طبيعي اكبر
ينقسم الى ممكن قسمه الى علاج يدوي وعلاج
حركي وعلاج الحركي طبعا في مدارس تحتوي
علاج جود يدوي في مدارس اخرى تحته
[موسيقى]
اغلب الناس صحتهم الحركيه جيده طبعا لا
نعم لان
الانسان خلق انه يتحرك احنا خل ناخذ اول
اول مرحله او من اوائل مرحله في نمو
الانسان المدرسه طبعا انت في المدرسه ثمان
ساعات قاعد حلو وبعدين يشتكون ليش هذا
الولد شيطان هو مو شيطان وهو طبيعه انه
يتحرك فانت خذيت مخلوق طبيعه يتحرك حطيته
بكرسي ثمان ساعات حلو شنو متوقع
طلعت مدارس مثل المنتسوري والمدارس اخرى
اللي تعتمد على
شغف الطفل او او خلينا نقول فضوله مع
طبيعه الحركيه فتلاقي انه ما في دسكات ما
في طاولات الطفل يروح من محطه الى محطه
يتعلم اللي يبيه يتبع يتبع فضوله بعدين
تروح انت للجامعه اللي هم اربع خمس سنين
من الجلوس وانا انسان حركي بعدين تنتقل
الى
الوظيفه ثلاثين سنه اربعين سنه الى
التقاعد بعدين تتفاجا انا ليش عندي مشاكل
متخذيت الانسان خارج بيئته حطيته اللي انت
صممتها
وبعدين تشتكي ليش في مشاكل فطبيعي اني انا
اذا ركنت سياره خمس سنين لما اشغلها راح
تكون مجيمه
يبي لها شغل ما راح تكون نفس السياره اللي
شغاله دايما فنفس المنطق يعني شلنا
الانسان من بيته الطبيعيه حطيناه في بيئه
اصطناعيه
فطبيعي انه حركته ما راح تكون سليمه بس مو
الانسان يحب يتحرك بس برضو الحركه تعبه
قويه جدا انه في الجلسه راحه
نعم يعني
تصميمنا حاليا للحياه
منطقي بالنسبه لي بمعنى الحين متجهين الى
متجهين الى كل شيء يكون اسهل وابسط على
الانسان لان مشكله الانسان الاساسيه من
سنين هي بالطاقه يعني انا ما عندي مصدر
طاقه لازم اروح ابحث عن اكلي تمام وعلى
اساس اتحرك ما اتحرك عبث اتحرك لهدف يا
اما اروح اشوف اكلي يا انحاش من مكانيا ان
تغير الجو فلازم انقل المنطقه رحنا وغيرنا
العالم كله وصار الحين كل شيء متوفر له
فليش اتحرك اصلا مالي هدف للحركه يعني
فعلا الحين انا وياك ليش نتحرك في سياره
تاخذني
في الاعداد كنا نتكلم عن عن
ان هذه هذي سالفه ان الانسان كسول او ما
يحتاج للحرق الحركه شيء شيء طبيعي لان
الانسان بطبيعته يبي يطلع اكبر مجهود باقل
طاقه بس الحين صار في وفره من الطاقه
فطبيعي اني اقعد فالحين صار علينا ان احنا
نفكر بمنظومه اكبر هنا بعد الهندسه تدخل
تدخل بعد
تصميم المدن فنشوف المدن اللي فيها حركه
دائما اليابان اللي في المدن اللي فيها
مترو المدن اللي فيها طبيعه حركتهم سليمه
اكثر منه يمكن يعمرون بعد اكثر منه لانه
تصميم المدينه صار وفقا لطلب الانسان انا
اروح من نقطه الف النقطه باء لانه عندي
شغل واروح امشي صديقه للمشاه صديقه بالضبط
بعدين اروح العصر باللانش بريك عندي اهم
شيء عشر دقايق والعشاء نفس الشيء وارجع
بعدين بالقطار فاكون مخلصه من عشره الاف
خطوه 12 خطوه بكل اريحيه المنطق اني اطلب
انا من انسان عايش مثلا بالكويت او عايش
مثلا في السعوديه انه يخلص 12000 خطوه
10,000 خطوه وين اسويها صعب بالضبط
المفروض جزء من تصميم حياتي
اذا سافرت برا في اماكن من المدن برضو
المخصص يعني في مو كل الاماكن بره صديقه
بس اي مدينه صديقي المشاه تدري انك تخلص
يمكن ما حسيت فيه
كانه عادي يعني
ان المنظومه وطريقه الحياه اللي نعيشها هي
خلتنا نعم لان لما نفكر الحين بالحركه
قاعد نفكر باني انا قاعد 24 ساعه واروح
امشي ساعه صح هذه الساعه راح تكون متعبه
طبيعي لانه في شيء اسمه
ان الجسم يتاقلم على الضغوطات او على
المتطلبات بشكل يومي فاذا انا الحين نسجل
ثلاث ساعات الجسم راح يقول انا بقعد هني
ثلاث ساعات ولان امير قاعد ثلاث ساعات
وعبد الرحمن قاعد ثلاث ساعات راح اخلي
الحركه اصعب عليه والجلوس اسهل فتقوم
تتغير الوضعيه واخذ الوضعيه اللي انا قاعد
اقوم فيها اكثر باليوم وهذه بتسبب المشاكل
واللي ممكن الجسم يتعود على ان الجلسه شيء
طبيعي فيصبح
المشي هو لسبب المشاكل اذا راح تكمل جلسه
طول حياتك ما راح المشاكل بس يعني كله على
على الدماغ او على طلب على طلب على طلبك
في الحياه يعني انت مثلا الحين انسان
رياضي وتبي تجري للجري في مؤهلات معينه ان
الوقت لازم يتحرك بشكل سليم
بس انت قاعد طول اليوم اللي قاعد تسوي
خلال اليوم وتاقلم جسمك على هذه الوضعيه
اللي هي الجلوس راح تكون جدا مختلفه عن
المتطلبات مالت الركض فهنيحنا بمشاكل ان
انت قاعد في ثني الورك او الفخذك قريب
اقرب لي صدرك لفتره طويله وفركض احتاج انه
فخذ يرجع ورائي شوي مع كل خطوه اخذها ما
عندي هذه المتطلبات وانا قاعد اخصب جسمي
على حركه معينه هنا ان احنا ندخل فيه
مشاكل
الجلوس يسبب مشاكل اكثر الانسان وللوقوف
شوف اي حركه ثابته راح تسبب مشاكل الاساس
الفريق التي او التنوع في الحركه فاذا انا
واقف فتره طويله ممكن تسبب لي مشاكل
بالظهر بمشاكل ونشوفها وايد عند اطب
الاسنان فيكون واقف طول الوقت يقول يا اخي
انا ظهري ذبحني ورقبت ذبحتني شوف لي حل
والحل اني انا اتنوع في الحركه اغير وقوفي
جلوسي اغير الوضعيه اللي انا فيها بين
فتره وفتره فاي ثبات هنا يعرض الانسان الى
الام او اصابات اكثر
البناء الى اناقه التصميم ورفاهيه الخدمات
مع تميز الموقع حلول سكنيه مبتكره
ومستدامه مع شركه صفاء للاستثمار المزيد
في وصف الحلقه
[موسيقى]
فيه
الدكتور فيصل سعود
فكتب تغريده اتوقع انه كان يرد على في
مقطع احمد الشقيري وكان احمد سكيري يقول
انه لازم الانسان يتجسسه صحيحه
فكان
يصير لانك انت لما تلعب على الجوال تصير
رقبتك مدنقه فيصير يعني 13 كيلو ويضغط
عليك او ان يكون دماغك يعني
فيصل ان انه ما في شيء اسمه الجلسه صحيحه
ان اي جلسه يجي الصحيه ايهما تميل الى
احمد ولا فيسك موضوع جدا ترى يعني المجتمع
العادي اللي ما لها علاقه في المجال
ما يدري ان هذا الموضوع في جدل كبير جدا
كبير جدا انه هل وضعيه الانسان تاثر على
وظيفته او حركته ولا لا امين لانه الصراحه
الطرفين
انه كل بساطه اذا انا قعدت في وضعيه معينه
لوقت طويل راح ارسل الاشارات لجسميه انك
انت حافظ على هذه الوضعيه فدائما يقول لك
مثلا اخصائيين او الباحثين بان انت لازم
تغير الوضعيه بين فتره وفتره اخر اذا انا
قعدت في وضعيه ثاني الورك مره ثانيه خلينا
نقول اذا كان هذا الكرسي او طوال انسان
طويل تمام
الوضعيه الفخذ راح تصير اقرب من الصدر
تمام في فتره اطول وراح يوصلوا عليه اصلا
اني اغير الوضعيه مالت الظهر كل ما ثنيت
الركبه اعلى كلما ظهري صار مسطح اكثر
لفتره طويله فانا راح افرق عنك في كرسي
منخفضه او ما راح اقدر اغير وضعيتي
انا الحين قاعد صعب علي اني اقوم واقعد
لانه ركبتي اعلى شوي من من وضعيه الفخذ
للحين الموضوع ترى فريش ما هو نهائي يعني
اللي يقول لك خلاص هذا
جواب نهائي ما هو ما هو كذلك تنصح فيه طيب
مثلا الحين الامهات ولا خلاص هذه المعلومه
دارجه انك اذا انك ترى هذا غلط انت لازم
تجري زي كذا فرجع ظهرك رجع ظهرك بس يمكن
هل ارجع ظهري ولا اقدم ولا
كل شيء
سوي كل شيء لانه يعطيك تنوع بالحركه ليش
لانه نشوف في مشاكل عندي اللي يرجعون
راسهم ورا ويخلون ظهرهم سيده مثل منهم
فئتين
العسكريين تمام
لعبات او لاعبين الباليه دائما هذه اللي
عندهم الاكتاف لازم ترجع لورا راسي بهذا
الشكل مع الوقت نلاقي بانه اعلى الظهر صار
بالعكس صار متيبس وانا لازم اكون عندي
قابليه على ان الاكتاف ولوح الجتف انه
يروح للامام ويرجع لوراء اذا خليته بهذه
الوضعيه فتره طويله وغصبت على هذا الشيء
راح ياخذ هذه الوضعيه ايضا فانا احتاج
الاثنين مو بس وحده احتاج التنوع احتاج
اني اروح في نطاق حركي كبير على اساس اقدر
اخذ دلوقتي لما متطلبات الحياه
تطلب مني ذلك مثلا في النزول اذا انا كنت
في
العسكريه او باليه نشوفهم دائما بان اعلى
الظهر حتى مع النزول الركوع مثلا يكون جدا
سيده او متصلب حتى لما تقول له ما يقدر
يرخي هذا الشاليه بحداتها لان ما اقدر
افعل عضلات معينه بجسمي اذا ظهري ظل
مستقيم طول الوقت
فجاوب على سؤالك بان الاثنين صحيحين ولكن
ما اتفق على انه الوضعيه ما تاثر على او
القوام او وضعيه القوام ما تاثر على
الحركه على المدى البعيد
بالنسبه للجلسات يعني
تفرق معك حتى على الكرسي بس
في عندك الحين
متربع بس مو لهدف التربع هدفين مثلا حتى
صحي اكثر
جلسه طالب العلم
شوف راح اختار التربع اكثر لان راح يكون
على الاغلب على الارض تمام فعندي حريه
بالحركه اكثر راح يكون في عندي قابليه اني
اقوم في مدى حركي واقعد اكثر
راح اطلب او راح يكون في متطلبات من الورك
من اسفل الظهر اعلى فنشوف مثلا
في دراسات صارت على
مقارنه بين قاع الحوض عضلات قاع الحوض عند
نساء اسويات نساء غربيات ما اذكر الدوله
الغربيه صراحه يمكن المقارنه بامريكا
وشافوا بان عضلات قاعد الحوض فيها قوه
ومرونه اكثر عند الاسيويات لانه ينزلون في
وضعيه القرفصه او الاسكوات اكثر من
الوضعيات الجلوس على الكرسي فراح اخذ انا
جسمي في مدى حركي اكبر وهذا دائما يكون
شيء صحي بس يعني اجيب يعني
انك لما تتربع انه بيكون مضر لان يصير
يمكن اني انا
لانك مو متعود يعني الورك عندك مو متعود
طبعا للاسباب اللي تكلمنا عنها الحين اغلب
الناس ما يتعود او ما يرتاح بالتربع فتره
طويله على الارض لانه اصلا وركه او الفخذ
عنده ما قد قاعد بهذه الوضعيه اللي تربع
فتره طويله بس تشوف
اللي متعودين على الارض عادي عندهم
شفت وثائقي قريب في نتفليكس عن
اللي هي المدن الزرقاء او او المناطق
الزرقاء اللي هي تكثر فيها معمرين وتشوفهم
في مدن مثل
في اليابان سردينيا في ايطاليا ثلاث ساعات
باليوم عندهم
الجاردنينغ او الزراعه تمام هذا في
اليابان فتنزل وتصعد ولا في شيء انا وياك
لو نقعد ساعه
ما في مجال بس هم متعودين فالجسم هذا هذا
الحلو بالجسم هذا هذا الزين وهذا الشين
بالجسم انه يتاقلم على اللي تعطيه اعطيته
جلوس راح احب الجلوس عطيته حركه راح احب
الحركه هذا هذا القاعده الاساسيه كل ما
كثرنا حركه
اخر يوم ان شاء الله بحياتنا كل ما كان
الوضع افضل بكل بساطه انت مو متعود على
التربه لذلك ما راح تلاقي مريح
اصح للجسم انك تاكل متربع ولا على طاوله
ما عندي الجواب الصراحه
طيب في
طاوله
ولا الوقفه المضره برضو لازم اقول مفيده
انا عندي وحده
تملك شركات
شو اسمه التنوع في الحركه نعم
بسبب الطاوله راح يكون مفيد للانسان
خاصه بعد اشوف انه خل نقول قبليتي على خلق
افكار وتفكير بعمق اكثر يكون موجود لما
اتحرك اروح وارجع اكون عندي طاوله اكتب
عليها
فانعم نعم طيب
الان كيف يعني اذا نجحتوي سلوك في جلستي
كيف اتعود كيف كيف اقدر القى المكان
المناسب بالنسبه لي اللي بيخليني يعني
بصحح كيف الموضوع عبد الرحمن نفس اذا قاعد
تحاول تعود على سلوك جديد في قاعده في
العلاج الحركي وفي نفسها موجوده في العلاج
السلوكي تمام اللي يسمونها جريده اكسبوجر
وانا كنت تعرض الشخص للسلوك اليديد شوي
شوي خل ناخذها على
مثال نفسي شخص عنده فوبيا من الاسانسير
تمام اول شيء تسويه تاخذه انت كمعالج تقول
له هذا تشوفه خليك خمس دقايق واقف بعيد
عنه ثاني يوم قرب ثالث يوم طق الدقمه
ورابع يوم شوف الباب يفتح ويسكر
خامس يوم اركب واطلع
سادس يوم اوقف خليك شوي بعدين نطلع ليه ما
يصير عنده عادي شنو انه يصعد وينزل نفس
الشيء بنفسه حق بالنسبه حق المفاصل تاخذها
شوي شوي الى مداها الحركه
اليديد اذا كانت تربع شوي شوي اعود عضلات
الضم على انها تفتح وتظل في هذه الوضعيه
تمام ومع الوقت مع الوقت راح تفتح معاي
طبعا في تمارين خاصه علاجيه او تصحيحيه
راح تساعد اكثر واكثر لان الجسم دائما
يكون في توازن ما بين العضلات الشاده
وعضلات المرتخيه على سبيل المثال اذا انا
صعب علي اني اتربع
راح تكون عندي مثلا
مرتفعه تمام معناتها ما عندي مرونه في
عضلات الضامه الداخليه اذا بساعد جسمي في
هذه الناحيه لازم اقوي العضلات العكسيه
اللي هي العضلات الخاطفه لان هذه عضلات
ضامه العكس الخاطفه وهي عضلات الارداف
الخارجيه كل ما قويت العضلات الخارجيه
للورك كل ما الورك صار عليه اسهل انه يفتح
اوكي في نظام او اني انا اتعرض لهذه
المدى الحركي
واني
اساعده عن طريق تدخيل عضلات اخرى اساس
يفتح الحوض معي شوي شوي اذا بفهم الجلوس
الحين اذا
بالخصه
بكون جلوسي صحي
ويساعدني في ان تكون حركه الصحيه اذا اني
جلست باشكال مختلفه اني ما اجلس على جلسه
واحده مده
اكثر من ساعه اني اغيرها ولا يهم بالضبط
وايش اللي انا بدي اسالك بالضبط ممكن توقف
تتحرك تمشي عشر دقائق ترجع نفس الجلسه
ممكن تكون انت ما عندك مشاكل
سببها نعم وفي بعد ايضا الحين قاعد يصممون
كراسي ملائمه لتنوع او او طلب الجسم
للتنوع مع الوقت اللي هي تصير مثل منصه ما
هي كرسي عادي منصه
كانها قطعه ارض بس مرتفعه فانت تقدر تتربع
ترفع لي لوحده تنزل الوحده وعلى اثرها انت
خلاص قعد قعدت تاقلم جسمك مع مع الوقت بس
لكنها شركه صغيره وتبيع يعني نوع واحد
ولكن شفنا مع الوقت راح تتوسع الا ما
تتوسع عندك واحد منها لا والله هذه طلبيه
بعدين بعدين الكرسي نعم ايوه
يعني متاحه بكثره
امره بسيط
كلها تطلع تنزل
الله يمكن لي اسبوعين
لانك مشغول قاعد تسويه مو وقتها
وبقت ساعه وساعتين وانا واقف وانسى انك
تغير اني اغير جلستي نعم
لازم تقلل ساعات العمل
صح لدرجه انه المنظومه ان اصبحت الرياضه
رفاهيه
يعني انت تروح تدفع فلوس في نادي عشان
تتحرك نعم بس انا وياك مولودين في جيل
النادي عادي صح في عالم اسمه
هذا
فيزيائي
ومهندس ميكانيكي دش في هذا العالم عن طريق
ركبته كان عنده مشكله بركبته قال الدكتور
شوف هذا التطبيق
1930 40 كان موضوعك عملية قالوا عمليه انا
بعالج نفسي واعالج نفسي واسس مدرسه فلما
امريكا شاف في ناس عند عند بار العقله
قاعد يتمرنون فسال اللي معه يسوون
قال ليش ما في حركه بشكل يومي يعني خلال
يوم ما ياخذون حركه ما يكتفون من الحركه
فكان مفهوم جديد وغريب عليهم نفس ما طلعت
الحين نوادي اول ما طلعت كان معروف
بالسويدي مع السويدي كان شيء غريب ترى مو
مقبول ومع الوقت لحاجتنا ويعني ادراكنا
اهميتها صار خلاص صار جزء من الطبيعه
بالنسبه للركبه
واحده من المشاكل اللي تصير للناس حتى
الرياضيين يعني من اهم من اكثر الاصابات
يتعرض لها الرياضي
وبالنسبه للناس العاديين خصوصا كبار السن
يعني
من
الاشياء اللي تصير لهم الركبه بس يعني ما
هي اقدر
صح الحين الركبه يعني اغلب حالات الركبه
المشكله مو من ركبه نفسها الفكره بالجسم
عبد الرحمن نفس عندك الحين شركه فيها خل
نقول خمس اعضاء
واحد من هذا الاعضاء عليه كل الضغط اوكي
كل الشغل عليه كل المواعيد عليك بالنهايه
راح يتعب
ممكن تعطيه اجازه يطلع هو اسبوعين ثلاث
يرجع فرش
بس لما يرجع لبيئه العمل راح يرجع يتعب فش
الافضل انك تسوي انك توزع المهام على
الاربعه البادئين نفس الشيء بالجسم الركبه
مفصل طايح بين الورك وبين القدم واغلب
مشاكل الركبه بانه ما في اتصال صحيح بين
الورك والقدم فالحين لما شخص يجي عنده
مشكله ركبه مزمنه ما اطلع الركبه ابدا
لانه هي الضحيه هي اللي قاعد تصارخ اذا
عندك طفل قاعد يبكي تدور منه طقه ما تروح
تقول انت ايش فيك اسكت صح فنفس الفكره في
نفس الفكره تروح تشوف الورك شو اللي ما
قاعد يسوي شوف شوف القدم هل قاعد تتسطح
وتتقوس بشكل سليم وعلى اساسه اقدر اعالج
الركبه واغلب مشاكل الركبه انا اعالجها
طيب وش اللي يسبب
الم الركبه
من العادات اللي الناس تسويها تسبب
اول شيء
بناحيه علميه
المدى الحركي في الورك اللي هو الدوران
داخلي فدوران داخلي هو لما تشوف ممكن
اطفال خاصه البنات يقعدون في وضعيات
الدبليو اللي هي الركبه الشيء داخل والقدم
تطلع لي برا هذا المدى الحركي مطلوب من من
جسم الانسان الى حد ما اغلب الناس اشوف ان
هذا المدى حركي عندهم قليل
فعلى اثرها يصير الضغط اكثر على الركبه من
ناحيه اخرى القدم خاصه عندنا في الخليج
تلاقي في انه في تسطح اعلى القدم قدم
مسطحه اكثر اوروبا واوروبا في تقوس اله
لكن اثنين هم اذا ما كان في دينميه في
الحركه راح تلاقي ان الركبه اهلي تاخذ
الحمل اكثر
العادات السليمه او شيء تلقائي اقدر اسويه
انا على اساس احسن من تقوس وتسطح القدم
واني اخلي الورك عندي مارن وقوي اني امارس
رياضات فيها دوران كل الرياضات فيها دوران
كره القدم فيها دوران دوران عباره عن من
القفص الصدري يروح لجهه والحوض يروح للجهه
الحين لما تفكر فيها لما انت تجي تمشي اذا
خليت خطوه اليمين اي ايد تروح قدام
الايجار نفس الشيء بكره القدم لما اللاعب
يشوت بريل لليمين
هذا دوران
هذا عباره عن دوران فكل ما مارشت عن
الرياضات فيها دوران اكثر اللي هي كره سله
القدم كل رياضه تقريبا فيها لا راح تحسن
من الركبه يعني انت قاعد تعطي الركبه او
او الورك مدى حركي اكبر
عشان تخفف الحمل عن الركبه نفسها طبعا هنا
عامل في عوامل اخرى تقول والله امير هم
الرياضات تسبب مشاكل بالركبه طبعا كل شخص
عن شخص راح يختلف في مداه الحركه في الورك
شنو قاعد يسوي طول حياته هل عنده اصابات
سابقه بالكاحل راح تاثر على الورك وعلى
اثرها تاثر على الركبه في عوامل وايد
مختلفه بس الانسان العادي خلينا نقول من
عمر يبلش العمر حتى قبل 14 يمارس رياضات
فيها دوران راح تساعد هذا الشيء اذا قدمت
مسطحه على الارجح ان رجلك ركبتك تكون
مو على الارجح كله يعتمد هي اللي سالفه
الالم او الاصابه هذه الاشكاليه انه ما
نقدر نقول والله هذا الهيكل راح يسوي بهذا
الالم لان الموضوع مثل طبقات اللازانيا شو
المجهود قاعد تحط عليه تمام بالاحذيه
عمرك الرياضي اصابات سابقه يعني هل انت
قاعد تمارس الرياضه صار لك عشر سنين ولا
توه بادي اوكي عصابات سابقه عندك مشاكل في
الكاحل ولا لا كلها تعطينا تجربه الالم ما
اقدر اقول ان شخص عندي قدم مسطحه او قابله
اكثر للتسطح معناتها عنده
في حالات نشوف فيها ان القدم مسطحه تعطيني
افضليه مثل لو تشوفين بولت يوسين بولت قدم
شوي اللي هو اسرع شخص في العالم
عنده قدم شوي تميل الى تسطح مو مسطحه مئه
بالمئه وهني في فرق بين التسطح الوظيفي في
عندنا نزول شويه بالتسطح واموره طيبه نفس
الشيء مع البرون جيمز اللي هو من افضل
اللاعبين كره السله في العالم هم عنده
شويه تسطح في القدم
مش مشكله القدم
بحد ذاتها ما هي مشكله ايه بس
القدم تمر في دوره اسمها دوره المشي انا
الحين عندك الايفون في
مثلا البي سي في
السوفت وير ماله في في شغله اللي يشغل جسم
الانسان هي دوره المشيكل اللي هي انا اول
ما اخذ خطوه تكون على الكعب منتصف القدم
بعدين على المشط هذي البرمجه ما عندك شخص
بالعالم راح يكون في خلل اذا مشى على
امشاط قدمه هذا مشكله عند الاطفال تعالج
كلنا نبلش احنا في المشي مع الكعبه اول
شيء هذا الطبيعي لما قدم تحوش الارض وهي
على الكعب القدم تكون في وضعيه التقوس
اوكي اول ما الوزن يصير فوق الريل كامله
القدم تبلش تتسطح ومع الدفع في اخر مرحله
ترد تقوس فاحتاج ان القدم تتسطح وتتقوس
في دوره المشي او مع كل خطوه اخذها وحتى
مع الرياضات فاذا عندي قدم مسطحه ما تتقوس
هني مشكله واذا عندي قدم مقوسه ما تتسطح
يعني مشكله لان احتاجهم لصحه القدم نفسها
صحه الركبه وصحه الورك كيف اعرف اذا رجلي
مسطحه ولا لا وخصوصا اذا ما كانت مسطحه
عندنا
لا مو مسطحه ايه يعني ممكن نحسن التقوس
اللي فيها
مع مع تمارين بس بس فيها تغوص يعني في بعض
الناس يروحون
صحي لازم القدم تكون في وضعيه عاديه فيها
شويه تقوس الحين في نوعين من الناس كنت
شوي انزل من شذي
يصير عندك الم في القدم على طول الناس
تروح عند دكتور مثلا يحولهم الى تصميم
احذيه المانيه
تكون مخصصه فعلا لقدمك
ويقولون لا لازم تلحين نحط قطعه اساس نقوس
القدم اكثر اذا انت قوصت القدم اكثر وحطيت
قطعه تمنعها من تسطح خلقت مشكله جديده
اللي هي ما تقدر تتسطح انا منعتها من
التسطح لازم يكون عندي الحركه الدماغيه في
في المجالين
اذا ابي احسن من تقوس قدمي في تمارين طبعا
تصحيحيه
لهذا الشيء
ونفس نفس فكره الورك مع الركبه التمارين
فيها دوران دوران كيف اعرف انها ولا لا اه
اوكي الحين اذا بنختصر موضوع القدم
راح اختصر شغلتين الحين المجتمع او
المشاهد ممكن يسويها اذا وقفت
عادي وقفتك العاديه حطيت ايدك على كتافك
ودرت كامل جسمك وطالعت وراك تمام القدم
اللي قاعد القدم اليمين اذا انت درت
لليمين المفروض انه تتقوس يصير فيها تقوس
اعلى نقدر نفحص هذا الشيء انا وياك بعدين
وفي نفس الوقت وهي قاعده تتقوس لازم يكون
في ثلاث نقاط الضغط متوزعه ما بين اساس
الصبح الكبير البهام ما بين الصبع الصغير
ما بين الكعب هذه الثلاث نقاط لازم يكونون
على الارض هنيه اسميه انا تقوس سليم حلو
اذا احد من هذه النقاط ارتفع في هذه
الحاله عاده نشوف وايد الصبح الكبير يرتفع
معناته التقوس غير كامل في تقوس بالقدم
ولكنه غير كامل لنا احتاج هذه النقاط يكون
على الارض عشان اشكل شكل الهرم اللي هو
قوي للقدم نفسها هذا فحص بسيط فيه فحص
فحوصات اقوى وادق تبين لي ارتفاع عظمه
او العظمى السفينه شكل نفس السفينه على
الارض واشوف تطورها مع الوقت وعاده عنده
مثلا هذه يفحصها
طبيعي
عاده وايد من طبيعي في ناس وايد انقل ملمة
بالموضوع وفي ناس لا اول ما تشوف الهيكل
المسطح يقول خلاص عندك قدم مسطحه روح فصل
لك قطعه داخل الحذاء او انه والله دير
بالك مع الوقت راح تتالم وهذا الشيء غير
صحيح لازم اشوف انا حركه القدم مو بس
هيكلها عشان اقدر احكم على وظيفتها
ثمانيه تكتب نشرات بريديه متنوعه ذكيه
وممتعه خليك على اطلاع بالتخصص اللي يهمك
والمواضيع اللي تشدك وتساعدك تكتشف
اهتمامات جديده تعرف على نشراتنا عن
الحياه اليوميه والافلام والكتب حتى كوالي
اشترك في اللي يناسبك منها وتوصلك على
بريدك مباشره نترك لك رابط الاشتراك في
الوصف
[موسيقى]
القدم لازم يكون فيها تقوس
يعني نوع من انواع التقوس ما راح اقول
والله حاد ولا فيها تغوص فيها فراغ ما بين
الجزء الداخلي من القدم وبين الارض هذا
الطبيعي في وايد ناس عندهم لا النفيكلر
هذه العظمه تكلمت عنها ملامسه للارض هذا
يكون خلاص هيكليا وهو ملامس للارض طبعا
نقدر نحسن من وظيفتها ولكن هياكلها ما راح
يتغير يعني راح يكون عندها قابليه شويه
على التقوس لما احتاجها ولكن خلاص طول
الوقت راح تكون هي مسطحه يمكن شوي ترتفع
مع الوقت بس مو ذاك الارتفاع القدم
المسطحه خلينا نقول الوظيفيه هي مثل
البرونجيم بولت القدم صايره متسطحه اكثر
شوي ولكن عندها قابليه على التقوس الفئه
الاولى ما عندها قابليه على التقوى
انا واحد منهم يعني قدمي مسح على الارض
ولذلك كانتعمقت اكثر في في موضوع
انا قبل ما يكون
ما حليتها اللي سويتها اني قويت القدم
اكثر لانه هي انا مو ناطرتي تتقوس ولكن
ابيها شوي تعطيني مناظرها تتقوس وهي ثابته
بس ابيها تتقوس شوي لما اعطيها حركه
التقوس تقويات بشكل يومي يا عبد الرحمن
يعني الناس اللي عندها قدم مسطحه عاده
عبالها الموضوع اسبوع او شهر او شهرين
وخلص انا اليوم الصبح راكض هني عندكم وادي
حنيفه وقبلها عشر دقايق ربع ساعه لازم
اشتغل على قدمي والحين قادر اني اركض 24
كيلو 25 كيلو من غير علم فادري ان هذه
نقطه الضعف عندي ولازم اشتغل عليها مدى
الحياه
ما لها علاج في عمليات بس نفس الفكره ترجع
اذا انا الحين اعطيت تقوس للقدم
عن طريق براغي وعن طريق تغيير هيكلي
للعظام منعت القدم من التصفح في وايد ناس
انسجه للحين متعود على الوضعيه القديمه
فهمت علي لازم اعود انا الساق شنو وضع
الساق عندك بعد العمليه شنو وضع الورك
عندك بعد العمليه ففي منظومه معقده اللي
هي يسمونه
[موسيقى]
ما اقدر اغير شيء واحد واتوقع ان كل شيء
ثاني راح يضل سليم لازم الاشياء الثانيه
بعد تتاثر لان كلها مرتبطه ببعض هل فيه
براند معين جيد للي عندهم رجل مسطحه الحين
مؤهلات
الحذاء خلينا نقول اللي اشوفه وظيفه للكل
واول شيء نكون نفس ما تكلمنا في البدايه
العرض التوبوكس او مساحه الاصابع تكون
عريضه لازم تكون عريضه لان الطبيعه لان
القدم طبيعتها عريضه من قدام واضعف من
وراه هذي كل قدم
لازم يكون القدم شوي في مرونه لازمك
الحذاء يكون فيه شويه مرونه بعدين نرجع
الى موضوع التسطح او
التغوص بانه يكون شوي مدعوم من الداخل اذا
اذا ابي امارس رياضه شدتها عاليه فبركض
على فتره طويله فتلاقيني الحين لابس هذا
انا ما في اي دعم ما في اي سبورت لانك
تمارس رياضه ابي اخذ ابي ابي قدمي تعتمد
على نفسها ولكن اذا بركض 25 26 كيلو هنا
احتاج شويه سبورت لانه بالنهايه القوه او
كثر ما امرنا قدمي لها لمت معين احتاج شيء
خارجي يدعمها
فالماركات هنا الماركات اللي افضلها انا
للقدم مسطحه وجهد عالي بروكس ماركه
امريكيه نوع معين ممتاز الصراحه وطبعا
الاداره اكثر اللي هو
يناسبني اكثر لاستخدام يومي اللي
استخدام يومي في شويه دعم او شويه بطانه
من تحت مو دعم ولكن يعطيك حاجز بينك وبين
الارض الالترا ممتاز
يمكن
شركه امريكيه او كنديه على ما اظن
مخصصه للركض ولكن عندهم احذيه يوميه وطبعا
الشخص اللي يبي كانه حافي الفيفو
مثلا ذكر العسكريه يرفضونك
مسطحه خلاص انت الموضوع وش العلاقه يمكن
هذا على معتقد قديم نعم لان اشوف وايد في
ناس عندهم قدم مسطحه وعادي فممكن
ان قدمه ضعيفه مع الوقت راح يتعب في البوت
ونشوف في ناس صحيح ترى يتعبون في ناس ما
تتعب فانا الافضل اني اقيم حركته طيب انا
الحين عندي شخص جاي قدم مسطحه انت شنو
تحتاج مني يا عسكريه شنو تحتاجين مني اني
اقفز مثلا ثلاث دقائق متواصله من غير علم
اختبرني فيه هذه اختبر الوظيفه نفسها اوكي
تبي تختبر قوتي الحين في اجهزه تختبر
القوه قدمك ضعيفه اوكي خلاص تحت هالكثر
والله
ما تقدر تطلع هذه القوه لا خلاص ما راح ما
راح نقبلك ناس ما هم يفحصون البوشوب
يفحصون
الركض افحص وظيفه القدم حط لي بليت حطلي
قاعده انط عليها وشوف ايش كثر انا اطلع
قوه وخليني انط من الجهه لجهه لان هذا راح
يكون صعبه على اللي عنده قدم مسطحه
وشوفني هل عندي مشكله ولا لا وعلى الاساس
يخدمني فالمعايير القديمه
احس ان في ناس كثير تفتي تدري اوكي فمثلا
كثير يقولون والله انت لازم تجري انك تنزل
القدم على ان هذا صحي ويخليك تجري
بانسيابي
في مقطع ثاني
برضو وكل هذه الرابط في النشره بس
نقطه ثاني يقول انه
تلبس جزمه رياضيه فكل المساعدات اللي انت
صحيح لو انك حافي تنزل على مشطك افضل بس
انت تلبس جسم رياضيه ففيها مساعدات اللي
ما عاد تفرق تنزل على كاحلك ولا ما تنزل
اني اثرها ما يفرق فما عاد تفرق كيف تجري
فهل في فرق الجري في معلومه مميزه انت
قلتها انه القدم تلقائيا تنزل على المشط
لما تكون حافي كنوع من انواع الدعم بس اذا
شفت انت العدائن العالميين راح تلاقي
الكينين وغيرها في اختلاف
في اختلاف ما بين النزول على ملكه بنقول
منتصف القدم وبين المشط اكثر الحين احنا
كلنا نحاتي من ناحيه والله اصابه انا بركض
بالشكل السليم لانه بعد خمسين ستين كيلو
بالاسبوع اركضه ابي ارجع اركض ما ابي
اتعور
فالابحاث تبين بان اذا انت نزلت على المشط
عرضت وتر الاكيلز العرقوب من ورا للاصابه
اعلى
واذا نزلت على الكعب عرضت الركبه للاصابه
اعلى فانت الحين
انت اختار انت انت وجسمك بس دائما نلاقي
بانه وحده من الشغلات المهمه هي مو بس
والله القدم نازل على المشط مكان النزول
انه لا يكون اوفر سترايدينج او انك تاخذ
خطوه اكبر منك بحيث ان قدمك
فكانك انت قاعد تدوس بريك مع كل خطوه
تاخذها تبي القدم تكون نسبيا تحتك يمكن
شويه سرعات عاليه بس تبيها نسبيا قريبه
منك مو بعيده
فالامكانك مال الركض معقد مو بس القدم في
عنصر الركبه الورك هل في عالم في عالم
هولندي حط اسس لهذا الموضوع بان انت لما
تاخذ خطوه خاصه
مسافات قصيره انه لازم الحركه تبدا من
الورك مو من القدم يعني انا تخيل انك انت
قبل لاقدمك تلامس الارض انت قاعد تسحب سحب
من الورك ففي عامل سحب يعني من الفخذ
الخلفي وياي من الارداف راح يساعد القلم
مع الالتماس
واحده من العناصر الاخرى ان ظهرك يكون
نوعا ماسيدا وفي شويه لينا وفي شويه
انحناء للامام
اكثر من عامل نفس ما قلنا مره ثانيه موضوع
له الطبقات وعده جوانب بس الاساس من ناحيه
الابحاث وهذا بعد صح صحي او او صحيح باي
ميكانيكيا بان لما تنزل على المشط تعرض
البطات لضغط اعلى فعرضه الوتر الاكيلز
الاصابه اعلى ولما تنزل على الكعبه تعرض
الركبه لضغوطات اعلى فعرضت الركبه للركبه
عرضه الاصابه للركبه اعلى كنت ايهما تختار
شوف مع مع سرعات اعلى طبعا طبعا كل شيء ما
حد يختلف عليه بانه في سباق مثل 100 متر
المشط ما فيك ما حد ينزل على الكعب شوفهم
كلهم
ولا واحد ينزل على الكابت تلقائي لانه انا
ابي اطلع اكبر فورس اكبر قوه في اقل مسافه
فطبيعي اني كاني قاعد اركض على اصابع يصير
بشغلوا الناس يعني تجري مره ثانيه انا في
هذه السرعات انزل اقرب للامام ولكن على
المنتصف القدم اكثر من الكعب طيب
في التنفس في النسخ الحاله بس ما مدى
اهميه يعني في ناس تقول لك لما تجري لازم
توزن التنفس معها فيقول لك كذاها كذا
ما اعرف يعني واللي ما يفرق قلت تتنفس
وجسمك بيعرف كيف تتنفس
صراحه بس عن تجربه لا هذا يصير اكثر سبورت
ساينز الناس اللي
متخصصه اكثر في الركض علوم الرياضه نفسها
انا لي علاقه اكثر بالمكس بس عن طريق يعني
عن تجربه شخصيه صح لما تنظم
تحس انه خلاص صار في ربط ما بين القدم وما
بين النفس في تكنيك صراحه
ابتدعته مع نفسي بس مع المجهود العالي
ابلش اعد عدد
كم مره اتنفس دقيقه ليه ما انسى لاني
تعبان مثلا معك الخطوه اقول له واحد اثنين
ثلاثه لقيت نفسي نسيت اعيد العد من الاول
واشوف اني اقدر اطول اكثر بس نعم صح كلامك
انفي في المجهود المتوسط
فمي عاد اخر ركضه لما يكون مجهود عالي
دقات قلبي وصلت 175 180 لا خلاص انا ابي
اقوى ما عندي استخدم الفم بس بالطبيعي لا
الانف وهذا الشيء انت طبعا تقدر تمرنا مع
الوقت ابليس البطاط دائما هي اللي تكون
فيها المشكله فتنشد عندي اغلب الناس
هو ما تنشد عند اغلب الناس
اكثر من الفخذ
لا نشوف اصابات ولا يعني
اصابات مثلا الاكيليس او البطات واصابات
الفخذ الخلفي
فنشوف في يعني توزيع بينهم اكثر يعني
كاصابات بس ممكن مبطات ما تكون جاهزه من
ناحيه قوه او من ناحيه مرونه يعني واحده
من الشغلات اللي خل ناخذها شوي من منظور
تعمير انك والله انت تعيش له مئه سنه في
هذه المجموعه التي تكلمت عنها في سردينيا
شافوا انه في علاقه ما بين ارتفاع المكان
اللي انت عايش فيه وطول عمرك اكسجين
تقعد تصعد مرتفعات الحين احد اهم
العوامل ان الشخص يفقد صحته وتدهور اكثر
هو السقوط شيئا انا وياك يمكن ما افكر في
حاليا بس اللي عندي عمره 70 75 80 يخاف
انه يطيح الحين شلي يخليني اقل عرضه
للسقوط قوه البطات وقوه الاصابع نفسها
[موسيقى]
اذا كان عندي رجل اقصر من اخرى كيف ممكن
الحين في في فعلا احيانا يكون عندنا رجل
اطول من رجل ولكن في اغلب الحالات يكون
في عدم اتزان في الحوض نفسه فلو تاخذ
الحوض
الرجلين من تحته اذا كان الحوض متساوي راح
يكون شكليا الارجل نفس الطول اذا ملت
بالحوض شوي هنقول ملت الى جهه اليمين راح
يبين بان الرجل اليمين اطول ولكن هي
المشكله اصلا في الحوض نفسه في الحالتين
اذا كان فعلا عندي رجل اطول من رجل او
عندي عدم اتزان في الحوض اي اوازن الحوض
شلون اوازن الحوض عن طريق موازنه العضلات
الارداف اليمنى مع الضمه اليسرى والعكس
صحيح فدائما في علاقه ما بين الجزء
الخارجي من الجسم مع الجزء الداخلي من
الجسم في الجانب الاخر فاوازنهم
وفي تمارين طبعا لهذا الموضوع مع الوقت
تلاقي ان الحوض صار سيده ومع الوقت تلاقي
ان الرجلين صاروا نفس الطول
اذا اذا كان الموضوع مو فعلا اختلاف
بالطول ولو في اختلاف بالطول نفس المفهوم
لان الحين ما تقدر تغير الهيكل تمام الا
في عمليات اذا ما تبي عمليات تقدر تقوي
نفس ما قلت الجزء الخارجي من الورك مع
الجزء الداخلي وتوازنهم ممتاز طيب بالنسبه
للانديه الرياضيه يعني
وش اكثر
الاشياء اللي يقع الناس فيها
وتسبب لهم مشاكل في حركتهم مساحتهم
الحركيه هذا انا طحت فيها يمكن انت طحت
فيها وايد ناس طافيه
التسرع مستحيل ابي اعظم بشهر شهرين ثلاثه
ما تصير مفاصلك مو جاهزه تمام فالتدرج اهم
عناصر
التقدم في النادي لازم يكون عندي تدرج
محسوم والحين الحمد لله صار في وعي بهذا
الشيء مع المدربين ومع الاخصائيين انت
لازم تتدرج حبه حبه والعب على عشر سنين لا
تلعب على سنه هذا احسن شيء
انك ترفع وزن اثقل من قدرتك
هل يساعد العضلات على انها تكون افضل ولا
ممكن جسمك اكثر من قدرات من اي ناحيه هو
الحين اذا قلنا ما تقدر تشيله ومفاجئ
خلينا نقول رفعه واحده هنا طبعا مضر بس
اذا كان شيء مدروس
بالعكس صحي جدا ترى هو نفس موضوع نفس نرجع
الى النفسيه اذا انت تطلع خارج زون او
نقطه الراحه عندك لازم تتدرج فيها ما يصير
انا انسان انطوائي اروح حفله فجاه ما ينفع
راح نتدرجه شوي شوي مع تدرج راح يصير في
قبول راح يصير في تطور عرفت ما تقدر
تستضيف مثلا اذا انت اول اسبوع ضيف ما
تقدر ثاني اسبوع ثلاثه اربعه منهك تصير
نفس الفكره بالضبط فاذا كان الشيء مدروس
ما في مشكله في الرفع
فاذا كان مدروس ومخطط له بالعكس سليم طيب
تخصيص عضلات محدده للتمرين
ايجابيه ولا سلبيه فتلقى ناس
يعني وهكذا
اذا بناخذها دائما ناخذ الموضوع لاخر يوم
بحياتك تمام احنا الهدف بان جسمك يكون
شايل نفسه
ليش شيخوخه فلازم يكون في ترابط قوي ما
بين العضلات اللي قاعد يصير في الباديه او
بناء كمال الاجسام اني قاعد افصل العضله
فصل واخصص هذا التمرين وهذا التمرين وهذا
التمرين لعضلات مختلفه فصل العضلات لحالها
لا يعني ارتباطها في التمارين المركبه او
في الحركات المركبه
لازم ادخل تمارين تربطهم على سبيل المثال
اذا انا قاعد اتعلم لغه قاعد اتدرب كل يوم
اقول
باكر ميم ميم ميم ميم ما راح اقدر اقول
تميس لا قلتها
تميس هنا يصير في ثلاثه في الحركه نفس
الفكره تقع افعل الباي باي باي خلاص راح
بس الباي تفعل بروحه لازم يكون في حركات
مركبه خاصه للرياضيين ما يمنعني انا اخصص
تمارين معين للعضلات معينه لانها ضعيفه
عندي بعدين ارد اشبكهم مع بعض
لازم نربط يكون موجود في الجسم لان الجسم
احنا اللي شرحنا الجسم وقلنا هذا الباي
وهذا الكتف الاسم ترى ما يدري جسم ما عنده
اي فكره من هذا اسمه
يشتغل مع بعض تبي ترفع ايدك راح ارفع ايدك
اي عضلات مالي شغل راح نرفعها تمام فهذا
هذا هذا اساس الجسم احنا اللي شرحناه
فالحين قاعد نشوف في توجه اكثر الى ربط
من خلال مدارس
مختلفه تشريحيا تشريحيا في ربط هذا مثبت
علميا ما بين العضلات الخلفيه للجسم كلها
من فروه الراس الى اخمص القدمين يعني قاع
القدم عندك مشبوك في البطات مشبوك بالفخذ
الخلفي مشبوك باسفل الظهر نصف الظهر
للفروه من فوق من ناحيه اخرى في عندنا خط
ثاني هذا بعد مثبت علميا ما بين عضله
الصدر عضلات الخواصر او الاوبليكس يسمونها
مع عضله الضامه وهذا الشيء اللي يعطيني
قدره على المشي بالطريقه اللي احنا نمشي
فيها فكل ما عزلت وتشوف اروح اي نادي
الحين في مدربين او كمال شوف مشيتهم سيئه
جدا ما فيها اي ما فيها كفاءه ما فيها
ترابط طبعا على يعني انت الحين احنا قاعد
نصمم العالم كله كله على انه
ناخذ اقل عدد من الطاقه لانتاج اكبر حركه
او اكبر سرعه او اكبر اي شيء الا في كمال
الاجسام ليش انت الحين مع المشي عند كمال
الاجسام حطله احسب السعراتها راح تلاقيه
يحرق اكثر من الشخص العادي لانه ما في
ترابط بالحركه وفي جهد على عضلات منفصله
بدل لا يكون فيها ترابط ونشوفها بعينك اول
مره الفكره
انت تقول ان الانسان
يفترض انه يسوي اطاله
دائما ناخذ ممكن اغير رايي شوي شوي عن هذه
الفكره الصراحه
شوف الانسان الثابت على رايه ما هو انسان
متغير ولا هو قاعد يواكب الواقع اللي قاعد
عيشه للحين انا على هذه الفكره الوحيد شوف
اي شيء اكستريم اي شيء شديد راح يكون مضر
الاطارات الثابته مثلا نشوفها ما بيزعلون
مني ولكن في اليوجا تمام اعرف فوائد
مدربين مدربات يوغا بس لما تاخذ عضله
وتمغطها زياده عن اللزوم وتقعد فتره طويله
وما عطيتها العكس ما عادت عضله العضله هي
نفس الربو باندا اوستيك عندنا ينمغط ولازم
مره ثانيه شنو ينقبل يعني اذا انا عودتها
فقط على الطول راح يفقد قبليته على
الانقباض اذا ما مرنت الانقباض
فهذه اشكاليتي مع مع
فتره طويله بس من جانب الاخر هي مفيده
للجسم مهمه للانسان
سؤال الصراحه
صعب يعني انا اميل الى ان تكون الاطاله
حركيه يعني يعني تاخذ المفصل الى مداه
الحركه اللي قادر عليه ويكون في تحكم في
هذا المدى على سبيل المثال شنو الفرق بين
اطارات الثابته والاطارات الحركيه
الاطارات الثابته اني اجيب انا جسم خارجي
او شيء خارجي او انسان ثاني ويغطني لفوق
تمام قطارات الحركيه اني انا اخذ المدى
الحركي نفسه واتم في اخر المدى الحركي هذا
واثبت في هذه الوضعيه ومع الوقت ازيده ففي
مدرسه اسمها
يتبعون هذا النظام اني انا اوصل لمدى حركي
كامل او او اللي عندي اياه اثبت هنا
واحاول مع الوقت اني ازيده فراح يصير في
فعاليه في الحركه لانها بالنهايه استخدم
انا الجسم انا راح اسوي الحركه ما في شيء
خارجي راح يسويها هذه الحركه
وعلى هذا الاساس ان العضله لازم يكون فيها
انقباض واطاله
لما تمرن متى تقدر تعرف او هل اصلا تقدر
تعرف انه هذا الالم اللي جاك في العضله
صحي ولا
اصابه هذا شوف هذا اشكال عند الناس اللي
ما يتمرنون يعني الالم العضلي يفرق وايد
عن الم مفصل يكون يسمونه
هو عباره عن صورنس او يعني شد او الم شد
ما هو الم مفصل نفسه ويكون بالعضله نفسها
لا انا من الاصابه ولما فاصل واضح مع
الحركه ما تقدر تتحرك خلاص مدى حركه معين
انت خلاص هذا في في الم يمكن اقدر ازيد
المدى شوي ولكن في الم بالمفصل نفسه اما
السورنسا والم العضله لا مختلف تماما من
ناحيه وصف او من ناحيه شعور كامل
عند الناس الجديده على التمرين تحسب انه
اذا صار فيه الم بالعضلات معناته انا
متضرر ما تفرق فيقولون مثلا في الم وهو
اصلا شد ما هو الم فلحم ما جربوا الاثنين
ممكن شخص يكون عايش الم لفتره طويله
ويحوشه شد خلاص صار في عندنا ربط ما بين
اي شد بان هذا سيء وهذه اشكاليه الصراحه
اشوفها خاصه عند كبار السن مو عند الصغار
لانه الصغار قادرين انه يفرقون بينهم
هل هو فعلا مفيد
هل كل انواع المصيده
واذا في انواع معينه تختلف يعني بدي اتكلم
عندك تجارب برضه انا الصراحه من اول
الشغلات اللي كان عندي اصابه في الكتف وفي
الكوعين وفي الكوعين
اي والله انا اقول لك يعني شو اسمه باب
النجار
فوالله كانت هي الصراحه البحث عن حل نفسي
قبل اي شيء ثاني
فاذكر للحين عمري 22 في الجامعه ورحت عند
اخصائي علاج طبيعي كان عندي الم في
الكوعين
لانك انت مستعيه افضل بسرعه وهذا
فكان التكنيك غلط اذكر التكنيك اللي
سويتها في تمرين كتف
فرحت له اول شيء حق دكتور اوه عندنا عرف
اه يعني يساعد بان اي الم جسمك تروح
للدكتور لا تقدر تروح حق اخصائي علاج
طبيعي لانه ممكن الدكتور يدخلك ترى بدوامه
تعال اشعه ولما يشوف الاشعه على الاغلب
لازم يطلع شيء غلط على الاغلب لان انا اذا
خذيت سياره الحين فرش طلعها اسبوع من
الوكاله اذا خذيتها عند الوكاله راح يقول
لك ترى يقول لها تبديل ترى لان لازم يقول
لك شيء انا فحصت لازم يكون في نتيجه نفس
الشيء مع الدكتور والله اقول لك من واقع
تجربه ومن الواقع اللي اشوفه انا
فرحت الدكتور غزني كورتيزون في
الكوع واذكرنا زاد الالم حزتها
بعد فتره قالوا لي امين روح علاج طبيعي
رحت علاج طبيعي كان اخصائي علاج طبيعي
قاعد
يستخدم جهاز خارجي بعد فتره سالني سؤال
حسسني باحباط مو طبيعي قال لي انت تبي
ترجع تتمرن صح يعني كان الوضعي ميؤوس منه
فحبتني شيء خيالي ولكن بعد تقريبا سنه
خلاص ترى في ناس حوشها الم خلاص تتاقلمي
انا فقمت اذا يعني عيال اقدر اشيلهم ولا
لا تخيل لهذه الدرجه لدرجه انه بعد لما
اسوق سياره البس مثل ضبابه فوق حول الكوع
على اساس اقدر اسوق يعني هذه الدرجه في
يوم رحت عند اخصائي ثاني كان كايروبراكتور
واللي ما يعرف هو يطقطق العظام ولكن ما
كان تبع الكايرو فراكتر كنت شايف اعلان
للاعب فرنسي يلعب ويمدح هذا المركز فرحت
له فدش عليه عبد الرحمن شخص طوله متر خمسه
وتسعين مترين يخرع
قال الامير شنو عندك قلت له والله انا جد
واحد اثنين ثلاثه قلت له اكثر بالجانب
الايسر
الحين بنسوي شيء شغله هنا تمام بس راح
تكون مؤلمه قلت له بس اوكي خذ راحتك انا
ما عندي غيرك
فمسك صبعه من الرسخ عندي الى
الكتف صعد فوق الى المثلثات وحسيت مثل
يعني
نار في هذا في خاصه عند عند المثلثات
كررها يمكن خمس ست مرات قمت قال لي يحرك
ايدك والله اخف
قلت تمام قال لي شوف عندنا احنا في
العياده وعد اذا انت تسجل جلسات ما تحسنت
فلوسك
والجلسه كانت بكلمتين وعشرين دولار حزتها
مبلغ ورحت ثلاث جلسات
هذا كان متخلي للماي فاشر او المساج ترخيه
العضلات وترخيه الانسجه وهذا المعالج كان
سابق وقت الصراحه قال لي امير شوف انت تحب
الرياضه وانت انسان رياضي تلعب كره سله
وتبي ترجع شوي شوي
فانصحك انك تشترك بهذا الويب سايت هذا
الموقع قلت له شنو هذا قال لي هذا راح
يحسن من المرونه يحسن ما ادري ايش واعطاني
كره
قال لي شوف هذا بعد الجلسه الاولى اذا ما
راح تستخدم الكره كل يوم ترخي بنفسك لا
تجيني قلت له انا كل يوم
والله اسبوع اسبوعين ثلاث
ملاكمه اموري ضد الطبيعيه
فحاشني يعني شعور انه شنو هذه المعاناه
اللي لمده ثلاث سنين انتهت باسبوع
باسبوعين ثلاثه
وصرفت فلوس وقعدت وحاتي المستقبل فدشيتهم
وكتبت شنو افضل انواع المساجد احيانا
بتعلم لنفسي طلع في شيء اسمه
لسيده اسمها ايدارولف
انا المدرسين ما كانوا دارسين لا اخصائي
علاج طبيعي ولا شيء
تمام
حيويه دارسه
ابتكرت التقنيه في المساج تشتغل على
الجهاز الغشائي الحين الجهاز الغشائي هو
الشيء اللي يغلف كل انسجه الجسم وحتى على
مستوى الخليه نفسها الخليه مغلفه بهذه
الماده الكولاجين اللي اسمها فاشيه يعني
اذا انا شلت العظام شلت العضلات
الدم وخليت بس الجهاز غشائي راح الاقي
انسان كامل عندي حلو فقالت انا بستهدف هذه
الفرشه او الجهاز الغشائي اللي هو وقت
العمليات ترى يشيلونا ويقطونه على بالهم
ما لا اثر
بايدي راح ارخي او اغير من طبيعه هذه
اللفافه او الغشاء عشان اغير هيكل الجسم
وهذا الكلام بال 1930 او اربعين يمكن وعلى
اثرها قدرت انها تغير انحراف العمود
الفقري بيدها
قاعد تعطي مثل امر لهذه الانسجه انها
تتحرك بطريقه معينه وعلى اثرها على مدى
عشر جلسات 12 جلسه الجسم شوي شوي يوازن
نفسه فكانت سابق سابقه وقتها وايد ففي هذا
النوع من المساج اللي انا بعدين رحت ودرست
وتعلمته بس من المدرسه اخرى اللي هو تلميذ
وفي المساجد العادي اللي هو ترخيات لكل
الجسم لحين المساج ايدول في تبع تقييم
كامل للجسم هذا يعيد التوازن للعضلات
وممكن ياثر على المدى البعيد على قوامك
على اتزانك فاحد القصص العجيبه لتوماس
اللي هو مؤسس مدرسه
يقول ياني شخص
مغني اوبرا عنده مشكله في الاحبال الصوتيه
تمام طبعا توماس اساسا مصمم له لا مهندس
ولا له علاقه بالطب كلش وراح درس مصمم
ازياء نعم او مصمم ازياء شيء جديد يعني ما
العلاقه يعني ما العلاقه كلش ما العلاقه
كلش
في هذا الشخص اللي هو عنده مشكله في
الاحبال الصوتيه
فشويه يعني تكسيرا منا ركز على بس الجزء
العلوي مبدئيا فقال ما قاعد يتحسن الشخص
خلني اعيد النظر بالجسم ككل اخذ تاريخه
وفحص شاف انه في مشكله في الركبه تمام راح
يشتغل على عضله خلف الركبه اسمها تمام
اشتغل عليها
في علاقه عميقه بين العضلات العميقه في
الجسم يسمون الخط العميق
ما بين الممتد هذا من لسان الى القدم ولكن
يمر في الحجاب الحاجز الغشاء حول المعده
عضلات قاعد الحوض الضامه عضله
الى القدم للاسفل فهنا هذا النوع من
المساج او العلاج اليدوي الحين في علاج
حركي وعلاج يدوي العلاج اليدوي هذا
او يسمونه
ينظر الى الجسم ككل
وحرر انسجه بايدي على حسب مكان العله اللي
يشوفها مو شرط يكون مكان العله هو مكان
الالم مو شرط ابدا اعطيك مثال
هذه من اواخر الحالات جتني سيده يمكن في
الخمسينات من عمرها تمام
ودشت علي اول ما دشت انا لاحظت ان البطن
منفوخ بصمه المنفوخ هي سيده يعني ضعيفه
ممتنه يعني ولا اتوقع انها هي حامل
فدشت علي وقعدنا اخذ تاريخ كامل لازم اهم
خطوه عند اي معالج ياخذ قصتك كامله انت
داش عليه انسان في هموم في اصابات سابقه
لازم اعرفها كلها تمام
فقلت لها الولادات كلها كانت طبيعيه قالت
لي كلها طبيعيه اللي اخذ وحده كانت قيصريه
وبعد العمليه القيصريه كان في انفصال عضلي
قالوا انفصال كبير وش تقصد لما عضلات
المعده تنفصل والمعده نفسها تمتد لبره او
تنتفخ تمام فيصير في ضعف في عضلات الكور
عضلات الكور نفسه
فهي ايتني مو عشان لا المعده ولا شيء الم
ظهر كامل من الرقبه الى العصعص والم
بالقدم
تمام قلت له انا بفحص الجسم كامل فمن
الفحوصات اللي سويتها هي حركه الضلوع مع
الشهيق والزفير المفروض
تتحرك للخارج مع الشهيق خاصه السفليه ومع
زفير تدخل لداخل طبعا ما تحركت ابدا
للداخل تمام وكان انفصال العضلي واضح
ولاحظت من ان المدى الحركي في الورك جدا
محدود
فقلت لها شوفي بس اعطيني شويه ثقه انا ما
راح اشتغل على ظهرك ولا راح اشتغل على
الورك ولا شيء لم نشتغل على الضلوع ونشتغل
على التنفس ونشوف ايش يصير معنا ترى اي
معالج يحط اول شيء فرضيات مبنيه على
التاريخ ومبنيه على الفحوصات ويجرب طلع
صحيح صحيح انا كل شخص راح يكون معقد جدا
انك انت تعرف 100% شنو المشكله من الفحص
لازم اجرب مجرب والله على اساس اي كلام لا
لا اجرب على اساس الفحوصات فالاساس
الفحوصات
وفي علاقه بين حركه
الصدري والحوض
على الجنب خمس دقايق تنفس مع مع حركه
معينه قاعد نسويها الجانب الثاني خلينا
نقوم اول ما قامت ليش حاسه اني خفيفه ليش
ظهري مريح ليش قدمي مرتاحه قلت لها ما علي
الحين من شعورك خلينا نشوف شو صار بالورك
هنا اثر الورك واضح على على الظهر
فكان الدوران داخلي او دوران الورك محدود
تقريبا صفر ما يتحرك ابدا الورك اول ما
نامت على ظهرها وحركنا الورك قام يتحرك 15
درجه عشان
اللي اقول اوف لانه ما توقعت نتائج من خمس
دقايق شغل على كل جهه
فمكان الالم من خلال هذه المدرسه المساج
غير
موضع المشكله فلازم نشوف وين المشكله
حركيا ونروح لها ما نروح لموضوع الالم لما
تروح حق مساج عادي ومساج رياضي تعورني راح
يمكن يمسج او يرخي عضلات الفخذ الاماميه
عضلات الفخذ الخلفي يمكن يصعد للورك بس ما
فحصك ولا سوى شيء بس
مفيد يعطي شويه راحه للعضله
يعطيها شويه طول ولكنها ما هو عمل دقيق
لموازنه العضلات
المساج العادي معروف وين الناس بس المساج
المختص هذا الحين
في ناس مختصه في هذا الموضوع
بالخليج صراحه قليلين اللي يمارسون شيء
يسمونه
يمكن في والله اقرب شخص شفته في في شخص في
الكويت غيري وفي اقرب دوله ايران بس انت
مو شرط انك تسوي سترايكسون اذا الشخص قرا
جسمك صح وعرف وفاهم ارتباط الجسم مو شرط
اصلا انه يلمسك على اساس تتحسن
وهو يقدر يعطيك تمارين وارشادات وفوق
عنايته وارشاداته ويحقق هذا الترابط اللي
نبيه طيب
الجاكوزي حار بارد المياه تفرق يعني مويه
الحاره مويه البارده
يعني راح تفك راح تفك
طبعا انا يعني ممكن عارف تسامح فيه
يعني رحت وقعدت معاه وخذيت كورساته
وهالامور طبعا الماي البارد يعطيك اثر
مضاد التهاب يعني ايه لانه يفرز
هرمونات ويفرز
شغلات مضاده للالتهاب فيعطيك هذا الشعور
بانك انت
فريش واثر ايضا من ناحيه اخرى الماي
البارد على النفسيه شلون ياثر على النفسيه
وشلون يخفف من هذا الالتهابات
الحين اذا كان عندي وعندي الم او عندي اي
شيء معياره كاسترس معياره كضغط على جسمي
خلينا نقول خمسه من عشره ما هو مساله
حياته ما راح اموت الحين ضغط نفسي ولا ضغط
اثنين جسدي الجسم ما يفرق بين الضغط
النفسي وبين الضغط الجسدي جهاز عصبي واحد
رده فعل وحده اوكي
خلينا نقول مستوى الضغط هذا خمسه من عشره
اوكي لما ادش بالمي البارد اللي يصير بانه
تصير الحين مساله حياته موت انا الحين
درجه الحراره صفر لازم اني يكون عندي رده
فعل
فليصير بانه يا انك انت تطلع وتفقد
الفوائد يا انك تقعد تواجه هذا الخوف
تواجه هذا الشوك او الصدمه للسيستم وتنزل
جهازك العصبي شوي شوي الى حاله انت فيها
مرتاح
حين الهم الاول شو صار فيه
تلاشى لانه صارت الحين فعلا في هم حياته
موت فانا غيرت بيئتي قلتها فعلا مواجهه
وعلى اثرها
تنضبط او منظوري لهذه الامور ينضبط وتشوف
اغلب الناس يطلعون من الحمام بارد حياه
سعيده وهذه كانت تجربتي معلومه هاف يعني
اول شيء ترى خصوص
ما حد يتابع يعني
صح لكن المقطع شفته يمكن كان لاعب دخل
وكانه نشل يعني من يعني
لحظه واحده
اللي راح تفرق معاك يفرق معاك هذا الموضوع
عنه كنت مؤخرا في انا اخر مره اسوي يمكن
حمام بارد او ماي بارد هذا بو اربع درجات
سيليزي يمكن سنتين او ثلاث بشكل مستمر
فعندي صديق وزميل لهني فاتحين مركز اكو
وفي المركز حاطين حمام بارد طبعا انا اخر
ثلاث سنين
بشهر الاطاف الكلام
اخر ثلاث سنين تعمقت اكثر في التنفس
الفاصل او او الزبده في تحكم رده فعلك في
الحمام البارد هي انك انت تتحكم في رده
الفعل الاولويه اللي هي الاوليه اللي هي
شاهقه اوكي اذا
ركز على الزفير كثر ما تقدر بس طلع زفير
طلع زفير خلي الزفير ست سبع ثمان ثواني
طلع زفير لا تاخذ شيء طلع الزفير اللي
قاعد تسوي قاعد تامر جسمك من خلال العصب
الحائر بانه يهدا فاخر مره نزلت ولا كاني
نازل بماي بارد اربع خمس يمكن قعدنا ست
سبع دقائق وطلعنا بس قبل كنت اسوي
جاهز جسمي وانزل الحين لا بس ركز على
الزفير اموري عادي قاعد اسولف وطبيعي
فالحكمه في الزفير
طيب
أنا ابغى اروح للتنفس بس ودي اقفي
الكاميرا
اخر بدي نرقب
نفسي تصير للرقبه الام
في التنفس
شوف اغلب مشاكل
اغلب مشاكل هذا ما ادري الصراحه اذا مثبت
علميا ولا لا بس
في في دراسات عن هذا الموضوع بس اشوف اغلب
الناس عندهم مشكله بالرقبه لما تاخذ
تاريخهم شلون اقول تاخذ تاريخهم يعني اذكر
لي الاحداث اللي صارت حول الاصابه يعني
مثلا الاصابه صارت شهر
اثنين اللي طاف قول لي شنو صار شهر واحد
شهر 12
فوق الخمسين بالمئه منهم يذكر انه صار في
حدث نفسي او استماعي او على مستوى الوظيفه
قوي فكان في ستراشر في ضغط عالي حزتها من
بعدها بلشت تطلع الام من الرقبه الحين
امير شنو العلاقه العلاقه هنا مدخل التنفس
لما انت جهازك العصبي يصير مشحون
مشحون يعني يصير يسمونه الجهاز السمبثاوي
يصير مسحون الحين الجهاز العصبي ينفصل
وظيفه الجهاز العصبي الاساسيه ابقائك على
قيد الحياه تمام
فيا انت مرتاح قعدت تهضم مستانس تضحك يا
اما في خطر او ستريس او ضغط تنحاش منه او
تواجهه تمام الجهاز العصبي مربوط ارتباط
مباشر في التنفس تمام لما تكون انت متوتر
تذكر اي موقف انت عصبت فيه او كان شويه
وتتهاوش تنفسك يزيد تمام يروح من مثلا 12
سته عشرين عده في الدقيقه الى 30 الوتيره
تزيد على طول
والبي احتياجي الطاقي
لمواجهه هذا الضغط حلو فهو بالاساس يحتاج
الطاقه جيت دقات القلب
استهلكها اكثر لان سيرين يرتفع
انحاش يا اواجه تمام الحين اذا طولت هذه
السالفه هنقول ضغط اجتماعي حاله طلاق أطول
اشهر انا دائما راح اكون في نوعا ما في
هذه الحاله السمبثاويه المشحونه وعلى
اثرها عداد تنفسي تزداد لما عداد التنفسي
تزداد راح استخدم العضلات الثانويه للتنفس
عظمه الاساسيه للتنفس حجاب الحاجز وعضلات
الضلوعات الثانويه عذرت السكيلنج عضلات
الرقبه عضلات التراس مثلثات ممكن بعد عضله
الصدر تساعدني شوي قاعد يصير في وضع الضغط
هذا استه لاك للعضلات الثانويه على انها
عضلات اساسيه وتجهد مع الوقت ويظهر عندي
اغلب الوقت الم الابهر
الم الابهر لو تتبع مكانه اتصال عضلات
الاسكينينجز عضلات الرقبه يتصلوا الى
الضلوع والضلوع تمتد من الامام الى الخلف
فاحس فيه كانه عند لوح الكتف ولكنه مو هذا
مصدره نرجع لمقوله انه مكان الالم ما هو
مكان المشكله
لها عامل نفسي
كانه والله عندي حمل على عاتقي شايل الهم
وتنفسي اتغير وعلى اثر هذه العضلات
الضعيفه الصغيره اللي مو مفروض تكون عضلات
اساسيه للتنفس تصير عضلات اساسيه تجهد
تشكل لي هذا العلم الجاهز فيه
فعلى الارجح
الام الرقبه تكون يمكن نفسيه اكثر منها
نعم تشوف ناس وايد مع التقارير مثلا ما في
شيء طيب شنو السبب ترجع بالتاريخ تلاقي في
مسبب يعني اغلب حالات الرقبه في مسبب من
اقربها يعني رقبه وابهر يعني سيده
انتقلت من المدينه الى مدينه تمام او
عندها اسف الام رقبه وجت لما خذينا
التاريخ لقينا ان تزوجت قبل الالم تمام
وعلاقتها الزوجيه زينه وكل شيء الى
المدينه الجديده والمدينه الجديده غريبه
عليها وكانت خايفه انها تترك اهلها وبلشت
المشكله تمام
تزامن النقله ما هو صدفه انا نشوفه مره
ومرتين وثلاث مع الناس
العامل النفسي انا اذا دائما في ذهني
لان هذا الشخص عالق في وضعيه في جهاز
العصبي مستمره احداث تتكرر ولما هذه
الاحداث الوهميه اللي خلاص خلصت تتكرر
بذهني جسمي يصدقها لذلك انت لما تشوف فيلم
خيال
فالجسم ما يفرق بين الواقع وبين الخيال صح
فهذا قاعد
تتكرر تتكرر تتكرر فلما تتكرر فيزيولوجيا
صار فيه فصل عندهم صار عندهم شحنه
سمبثاويه مشحون دايما جهاز العصبي وما صار
عندهم اكسس او مدخل الى الراحه شلون
ندخلهم من الراحه عن طريق التركيز على
الزفير تمام ولما نركز على السفير نفعل
عصب اسمه العصب الحائر اللي هو يامر الجسم
بانه يرتاح
دقات قلب تنزل
عادي التنفس تقل ويرجع شوي شوي جسمه من
ناحيه ايضا
كيميائيه يتغير
حمض الدم عنده يتغير شوي شوي على المدى
البعيد يستقر ويقدر يتعايش مع احداث
اليوميه نجيب بالنسبه للرقبه لسه احيانا
مثلا الصلاه
طويله
الام في الرقبه
شوفوا اغلب الناس بسبب الوضعيه اللي احنا
قاعدين فيها
عضلات اعلى الظهر
من غير فعال عندهم عند الوقوف احنا عند
الوقوف لازم يكون كثر ما اقدر في مشاركه
ما بين عضلات الفخذ الخلفي عضلات الارداف
عضلات اسفل الظهر واعلى الظهر اغلب الناس
في اعلى الظهر ما عندهم تفعيل فلو تلاحظ
اقرب شيء لرقبه هي عضلات على الظهر فاذا
قدرت افعل عضلات على الظهر اكثر
القبر راح يكون عليها ضغط اقل قوام اصلا
بعد شوي يصير في توازن اكثر ما بين الرقبه
وبين القدم لذلك يقول لك يعني في خلاف على
موضوع والله حين فتره طويله هذه وضعيه انا
ثابت فيها وقعد تؤثر على المي فما اقول
اني اقول انه والله وضعيه القوام او
الطريقه اللي اقعد فيها ولا اقف فيها ما
تاثر
فمشاركه الحمل ما بين اعلى الظهر والرقبه
راح يخفف الالم في الركوع
دخلنا
ركبتك ولا افضل انك تمدها الحين السنه
المفروض يكون عندك القبيله على اثنين بس
ايه لا بس اذا الركبه لا يعني
في صحتك الحركيه
معناته عضلات الفخذ الخلفي عندك وممكن
البطات وممكن عضلات العميقه للارداف تكون
مشدوده انا لازم يكون عندي قابليه على انه
لما اركع ركبتي تكون سيده ويمكن شوي اكثر
من سيده تكون ممدوده شوي لوراء هذا الشيء
مطلوب لجسم الانسان مو معناته اذا سويت
العكس من تلقاء نفسي شيء سيء ولكن لازم
القابليه على الاثنين
في اللي يقول لك برضه اتذكر هذه يعني
هذه الحلقه فيها وايد اغلاط يعني
اذا انت عرفت الاطاله اللي تنزل الى رجلك
بس تكون من رجلك ممدوده فانه كل ما قدرت
كل ما زادت انه معناته ان صحتك غير صحيح
غير صحيح 100%
اكثر مؤثرين يعني الصراحه كل التقدير لا
على اللي على اللي سواه يمكن احنا هذه
الفكره موجوده من اخصائيين نفسهم يعني
فكره منتشره بس ما في علاقه بين المرونه
وبين الصحه بمعنى لا بمعنى كل ما زادت
مروني مرونتي زادت صحتي لا هعطيك مثال في
وايد من مدربات اليوجا يعانون في صمت
واحده منهم طلعت وتكلمت بالموضوع اسمها
جيل ميلر من اكبر مدربات ومعلمات اليوجا
في امريكا من كثر ما تسوي اطارات
معناته في مدى حركي كامل في الفخذ وفي
الركبه فقد الورك عندها قبليته على
الوظيفه الصحيحه ما صار ما صار يتحرك بشكل
صحيح فبعد فتره صار في الم شديد تمام وسوت
اوبر سترتش او استرتش زياده على اللزوم
للورك واضطرت ان تسوي عمليه تبديل ورك في
عمر يمكن الثلاثينات او الاربعينات يعني
جدا صغير وكلها كان نتيجه النهائي اصلا
عندها مرونه وفوق المرونه تزيد عليها
مرونه فالجسم خلاص فقط قابلته على
الانقباض صار كله مارنب مرن صار كانه
معكرونه
ما في اي انسجه ثابته فهنا هنا الاشكاليه
في مؤشرات سليمه للمدى الحركي ما نبي
نتخطاها الا اذا رياضتي تتطلب هذا الشيء
بس حق الشخص العادي لا ما معنى كل ما صار
عندك مرونه زياده معناتها صحتك افضل
شنو اثرها اهلي زينة
بعدها براحه والله في علم كامل على هذا
يعني في
ممكن يصير معك او خلينا نقول تسوي الحركه
العكسيه انه مستشعرات الحركه عندك في
العضلات قاعد اقول لك ترى طولت
نفس القطوه لما تقعد فجاه تلاقيها بغضت
نفسها هذه المستشعرات الحركه عندها خلاص
قالت لها سوي هذه الحركه فاول ما تقعد من
النوم الصبح شلون تتمغط لا اراديا
فتسوي الحركه العكسيه اما طبعا علم
الصوت
في في طق طبعا الفقرات
بس هذا علم يعني كامل الصراحه اللي هو
كارو
ما عندي درايه كافيه اني احكم والله
يعني هل هي لها مخاطر ما ادري ما ادري
صراحه ما ادري لا والله
طيب عادي اقول ما ادري
صحتين
طيب في قلت اعدل حركاتك يتعدل نومك
وش علاقه تتحرك منهم انت لما تعدل
الحركاتك معناته الضغط على المفاصل نفسها
وتوزيع الحمل يتوزع تمام فالحمل نفسه على
الجسم يخف فعلى اثرها جسمك ما راح يكون
شايل تنشن او شايل شد لفتره طويله خلال
اليوم ويقدر يريح وانت تشوف بعد في تنويم
مغناطيسي شو يسوون عبد الرحمن
الحقيقي اصلا نعم نعم لا لا علم كامل يعني
من زمان والحين صاروا يدخلونه في العيادات
يعني انا مجرب التنسي اربع مرات اقرب شيء
للسحر المغناطيسي
لتغيير العادات نعم نعم تنام بس هي بان
بين النوم هي بين النوم وبين استيقاظ يعني
وفعلا لما يقول لك ثري
بس من طرق من طرق تنويمك مغناطيسيا او
تريح الجسم ودخوله في هذا
ذهنيا انه على جزء جزء جسمك ويقول لك رخ
الاكتاف رخ الكوع رخل
الركبه وغيره وتلاقي نفسك شوي شوي ارتخيت
ونمت فاذا عندي جسم انا مشدود
لسبب نفسي او حركيه او ايا كان راح يكون
في صعوبه اكثر عليه على الاسترخاء
فهذا الربط يعني خلينا نقول من ناحيه جهاز
عصبي تقول التنفس السليم يحول الهواء الى
دواء نعم
اول شيء
اصلا ممتاز تعريف التنفس الوظيفي كالتالي
يرجع الى جزء تتنفس
وجز اخر كيميائي او بايو كيميائي اللي هي
تدخل في عدادات التنفس اللي تاخذها وتحمل
كلي ثاني اكسيد الكربون وامور اخرى من
ناحيه ميكانيكيه من ناحيه حركيه لما اخذ
النفس المفروض الجسم من تلقاء نفسه هذا
عند نعتبر النفس وظيفي نفسه لضلوع السفليه
تتوسع بشكل 360 درجه ضلوع السفليه اللي هي
تحت عند الخواصر تتوسع بشكل 360 درجه
والجزء العلوي من الصدر ينتفخ شوي للامام
لازم هذين المتطلبين على اساس اعرف انه
الجسم قاعد ياخذ الهواء باقل مجهود ما
يكون في سترس عليه جزء اكثر من اخر الحين
الناس عندهم مثلا مشاكل بالاكتاف نلاقي
بان في تنفس سطحي ولما ياخذ النفس اكتافه
ترتفع
ما يقدر ياخذ نفس من غير ما يحرك اكتافه
انه العنصر الحركي مهم لصحه الاكتاف ولصحه
الرقبه وهذا اهم شيء اقيمه عند اي شخص
عنده مشكله بالكتف والرقبه تمام من ناحيه
كيميائيه
نشوف وتيره التنفس الشخص تم نفس قاعد ياخذ
في الدقيقه تمام ما في اتفاق علمي بان هذا
العدد هو السليم ولكن نشوف ما بين ثمانيه
سته الى 18 اوكي اكثر من ذلك انا اعرف
الشخص قدامي قاعد يتنفس زياده عن اللزوم
الحين شنو يعني يتنفس زياده عن يعني عنده
شيء يسمونه او تنفس في الدقيقه فوق 18 او
عشرين
عده في الدقيقه شو اللي يسوي هذا في الجسم
يزيد مستوى الاكسجين في الدم اوكي لما
يزيد مستوى اكسجين في الدم الحمض نفسه
يتغير حمض الدم يتغير يصير قلوي اكثر يمكن
وايد تسمع بانه القلوي شيء زين اوكي توازن
شيء زين اللي هو حمض الدم يكون بين 7.35
الى سبعه خمسه واربعين شوف الدقه لازم
يكون في هذا الحد اذا صار قلوي اكثر اللي
يصير بانه الاكسجين يظل في الدم مع
الهيموجلوبين والخلايا يشبص فيها
معناته تقل نسبه الاكسجين اللي قاعد تروح
للانسجه
فلازم نعادل هذا الشيء عن طريق التركيز
على الزفير يكون عندي ثاني اكسيد الكربون
اعلى في الجسم الحين تتراوح انا عداد
التنفس في الدقيقه بين شخص وشخص باقي هنا
ست عدات في الدقيقه يعني هو تقريبا كل
12 ثانيه تقريبا خمس عدات يعني عشر ثواني
كل عشره ثواني ياخذ نفس واحد فخمسه انهيل
وخمسه شهيد خمسه سفير يسمون هذا الجولدن
او النفس الذهبي
وضعها طبيعي 14 وضعها طبيعي بس عاده نشوف
كل ما زادت وتيره التنفس كل ما قابليه
تحمل الستريس قلت عند الجسم نعم لان
في دراسه حديثه سموا السي اوتو
هذه الجزيئه اللي تسبب لي الستريس في
الجسم مدري سياخذ
على الموازنه بالعكس اذا ما عندي مستحيل
لانسجه تستقبل الاكسجين
تخيل يعني الجسم عنده مستشعرات لثاني
اكسيد الكربون وهي اللي يخليك تتنفس يعني
في شيء
بقاع اسمه
هذا يحدد كميه ثاني اكسيد الكربون عندك في
الدم اذا ارتفعت هني تاخذ الشهيق مو العكس
يعني مو اذا نزل الاكسجين لا اذا ارتفع
ثاني اكسيد الكربون اوكي فالدراسه اللي
صارت اللي قالت انه ثاني اكسيد الكربون
جزيئه الخوف كان على مراه عندها مشكله في
جزء من المخ اسمه الاميجله هذا هو يعطيك
استشعار للخوف
هذه غير موجوده عندها استشعار الخوف غير
موجود عنده ما اذكر لي خلل فيه او فقدان
جزء منه ما اذكر بالضبط بس هذه المره ما
تخاف من ولا شيء والروح افاعي ما تخاف
حريقه ما تخاف ما تخاف من ولا شيء هم صار
لها حادثه تم خطفها واعتداء عليها وما كان
في اي رياكشن ما كان في اي خوف فما تخاف
من من الغرباء او السترينجر
فقالوا بناخذها نحقنها
راح ناقد فيها كميه بسيطه من ثاني اكسيد
الكربون اول ما حطينا فيها حاشتها حاله
هلع قالت وقفه رجاء ردوني الوضع الطبيعي
انا خايفه انا اول مره تحس في خوف في
حياتها
فكل ما احتمائك تحمل كلي ثاني اكسيد
الكربون زاد تحملك مو مستوى التحمل ثاني
اكسيد الكربون زاد كل ما اعصابك هدت اكثر
وكان عندك قابليه على تحمل الاسترش
في تمارين تخليني اتحمل ارفع من زياده
كل ما طولت في حبس النفس والزفير فمثلا
فيه شيء جدا شائع له فرصه اربعه شهيق سبعه
احبس النفس بعدين ثمانيه زفير انا شوي شوي
شذي قعدت ازيد تحملي ثاني اكسيد الكربون
في طريقه اخرى طبعا الفرصه الكل اللي اقدر
اسوي اسوي يسمونه او تنفس الصندوق ابلش
اول شيء عدتين راح يكون عدتين شهيق عدتين
وقفه عدتين زفير عدتين وقفه وعيد فتصير
على شكل صندوق او بوكس او مربع تمام قدرت
استحمل العدتين عادي وضعك طبيعي لا انك
والله اضطريت انك توقف ولا شيء اروح الى
الثلاث عدات طبعا اسوي العدتين على مدى
مثلا دقيقتين اشوف وضعي اوكي اروح لثلاث
عدات وضعي بثلاث عدات ممتاز اروح للاربع
عدات والمستوى اللي اوقف عنده خل نقول انا
الحين اقدر ادخل مثلا خمسه بخمسه بخمسه
بخمسه وضعي طبيعي شفت انه سته اصابع علي
ابلش امارس الاربع عدات اللي هي اقل شويه
مستوي العادي
اربع عدات لمده عشر دقايق في الليله
كل ليله ليه ما تشوف انت وضعك طبعا هنا
الاشكال دائما نقول والله لمتى الانسان
متغير يعني انا احيانا يكون عندي ضغوطات
امر بحالات تصير لي ظروف فقط ولا غيره
جسمي كله وحياتي كلها تتغير فرد اعيد
تقييم نفسي واشوف شو اللي احتاج هزتها انا
مجهد مثلا اليوم انت عندك تصوير من الصبح
لليل حتى عشر دقايق اخلي التلفون على صوب
اتنفس انا ادري باكر عندي يوم مهم وبهذا
الشكل انا احسن من عندي كيف اعرف اني
اتنفس بشكل صحيح
شوف لما تروح عند الدكتور عبد الرحمن وين
احط عاده السماعه على الصدر على الظهر من
فوق لان النفس لازم يبعد في شي يسمونه
اللي هي الفجوه الخلفيه للصدر
الهواء يوصل لها ويصير فيها انتفاخ فبكل
بساطه انت قاعد عادي تقدر تحط ايدك على
ضلوعك واذا خذيت شهيق
هل تشوف في توسع بين الاصابع ولا لا
المفروض الاصابع تروح بشكل تسويها الحين
المفروض تشوف في توسع بشكل جانبي للضلوع
وما تشوف ارتفاع وايد بالصدر يمكن تسوي
يعني ما يكون فيه ارتفاع بهذا الشكل يكون
فيه توسع من غير حركه تمام ومن ناحيه اخرى
الاكتاف ما ترتفع والنقطه الثالثه بان
الجزء الامامي والجزء الخلفي من الصدر شوي
ينتفخ او يصير في تحرك الحين شلون الجزء
الخلفي يتحرك نام على ظهرك على الارض
وجربها حسيت والله في ضغط من الارض عليك
لما تنفست معناتها في في مساحه قاعد تصير
عندك من ناحيه اخرى بكل بساطه لك 30
ثانيه او دقيقه وشوف من غير ما تتحكم كم
نفس قاعد تاخذ في الدقيقه
تمام يعني ما في شيء متفق عليه الصراحه بس
انه ما بين خلينا نقول الثمانيه الى 14 16
طبيعي
فوقه يعتبر عندك او
كثره في الشيخ والزفير
خلينا نشوف نحاول اذا انت في تطبيق الصحه
يعطيك صح اتوقع اذا اتذكر نسبه الاكسجين
الدم صحيه ممتاز
عندي
16.8 الى
27.27 راح تكون يمكن تسولف ايه طبيعي لان
طبيعي لازم اطلع على الحين لما اتكلم قاعد
اطلع زفير فاداه شهيق اخذها اعلى اذا هذا
27 انت شوف نفس في الدقيقه نعم حلو لو انك
انت
مراقب هذا
العدد خلال اليوم خلال الشغل خلال النوم
خلال الراحه اذا بالراحه قاعد توصل 27
لاعب في شيء غلط مخك
شوف وقت النوم بعد شوي ترى يرتفع لان كنت
نايم على ظهرك يعني يصير يمكن 14 انت خلاص
انت سته عشر يعني اذا ارتفع وايد الى
العشرين 22 هني انت شوف الايام هذه يعني
نام شوف يوم التصوير شو يصير
يوم اللي عندك
وقت التمرين طبيعي راح يرتفع هذا شيء عادي
بس انه انا قاعد تمام يعني مثلا قبل
اللقاء طبيعي انه يكون في عندي توتر على
طول الجارمن تقول لي
انا شلون تعرف من
تعرف من معدل تغير نبضات القلب وتعرف بعد
من الاسبريشن
فتعطيك تنبيه
يعني
عندك
شنو عاده يعني هو ترى فيه معدل صحي لكل
شخص مختلف عن شخص اي شخص
[موسيقى]
80 ففي ناس عندهم طبيعي اثر في عالي بس
يقيس نفسك بنفسك
فيعطيك انت المعدل العالي مالك
بعدين يشوف انت وقت الراحه شنو يعطيك
عندي اللياقه القلبيه تحت المتوسط
حلوه بس صناعيه هذه هذا عيبها يعني المواد
حنيفه تروح تم ريحه مزارع
ونزول وصعود
لا لا
تبين
والله عندي
صديقه اسمها منى شهاب تعرف منى شهاب
يتسلقت افرست
تصعد ما هي هاويه هذا الشيء
عن طريق الفهم ايش الفرق بين التنفس عن
طريق الفم الانف هل الشهيد والزفير يعني
تاخذ من الانف وتطلع من الفم اعطني وقت
الراحه لاثنين من الانف نعم مئه بالمئه
يعقم الهواء
يفرز ماده
جدا مهمه لان تخفض الضغط وهي نفس الماده
اللي استخدموها بعد اكتشاف اثرها على
الجسم في الفياجرا
فتوسع الشرايين وهم النايتروك اوكسايد
مضاد للالتهاب فعندنا هذه الخاصيه بالالف
ما عندنا اياها في الفم بعد الانف يعطيك
شويه او ضغط لان الفتحات اقل
في الهواء يوصل الى مناطق اعمق او اللور
لوب او الجزء الاسفل من الرئتين بنستفيد
منه اكثر
تتنفس من الفم في حالات الشده العاليه بس
الحين في ايه
اللي هو احد العلماء في علم النفس
وتاثيرها على الصحه الرياضيه عنده شيء
بسيط جدا يوضح لك مثل الف متر من الفم
يقول لك انت ايش اسم الجير سيستم او نظام
الجير اوكي
الراحه من الانف
شده شويه ارتفعت خلينا نقول دقات قلبتك
وصلت 110 120 للحين من الانف صارت اعلى
وصارت 150 160 مو قادر استحمل شهيق من
الانف زفير من الفم اوكي 180 190 وفوق فم
فم
لانه خلاص الحين انا مو وقت صح وقت اداء
ابي اخذ اكبر عدد اكسجين واطلع كل ثاني
اكسيد الكربون اللي عندي على اساس اقدر
اصمل فيه في السباق او في الرياضه اللي
قاعد اسويها ولما انزل عشان الاستشفاء
اسوي العكس فراح اخذ فاكون انا الحين خل
نقول ركزت 400 متر تمام خلاص راح اكون انا
وصل حدي راح يكون من الفم اذا بنزل بنزل
الى من فم فم الى انف فم الى انف انف
وعود نفسي على هذا النمط ممتاز بالنسبه
للتنفس من الفم وهو سبب الشخير
نعم اختناق نومي تمام التنفس من الانف
وبعد لازم نربط شغلتين ببعض يا عبد الرحمن
وايد مهمين بان انت فيه وضعيات
لما يكون جهازي العصبي مشحون تلقائيا
الجسم يبي يوظف طاقه اكثر فيتحول الى شنو
تنفس فموي تمام الحين هذا السيستم
انا اقدر بسبب بسبب الموقف اللي انا فيه
يتغير التنفس ولكن نفس الوقت اذا غيرت
التنفس راح تغير حالتي الفيزيولوجيه فاذا
تنفست من فمي تلقائيا قاعد يعطي اشارات
لجهاز العصبي انه فيش في ضغط تمام لذلك
تلاقي الناس يتنفسون من الانف اسف من الفم
زياراتهم لعزك الله الحمام عاليه بالليل
لان شو يصير لما يحوش الجسم يقول لك فرغ
المثانه هذه خاصيه موجوده على اساس اذا
انت واجهت ذيب ولا شيء تكون اخف فرغ
المثانه وتركض تمام
فنفس الصفه اللي موجوده في الجهاز العصبي
من الف سنه موجوده حاليا ما صار في اب
جريد نفس الشيء بالضبط تمام فلما اتنفس من
الفم اعطي اشاره الجهاز العصبي انه انا
الحين مشحون وعلى اثرها كل شيء يشتغل مع
بعض دقات القلب تزيد المثانه وجهه عزك
الله تفرغ فاروح الحمام في عندي شيء تقول
لي امير انا تبهذلت
والله من السكر ومن غيره قلت لها زين
خلينا نجرب التالي تمام
مبطل خلال اليوم خلينا نجرب بس عشر دقايق
الانف وغيره عشر دقايق ربع ساعه قبل النوم
كم مره
تقومين من الحمام او تروحين للحمام تقدر
تعطيني تجربه كذا
تايمر عشر دقايق حط التليفون على صوب تمام
اربع ثواني ان اربع ثواني هولد او اربع
ثواني اخذ الشهيق على اربع عدات بعدين
اربع ثمانيه اوقف بعدين اربع ثمانيه زفير
فابطئ الزفير بعدين اربع ثواني اوقف مره
ثانيه من غير نفس واكرر عشر دقيقه كلها من
الانف كلها
لان ابي عاطفيه واعطي اشاره لجسمي نريح
الحين مو فم نشحن
عشره دقيقه ربع ساعه شفت هالاسبوع اللي
بعده قلت لها بشري كم مره رحت الحمام قالت
لي اربع مرات اربع ايام من الاسبوع ما رحت
ولا مره فرح من الثمانيه الى صفر
فتخيل انت الحين منظومه العلاج الطبيعي او
الصحه او العلاج معتمده علي كاني انا عالج
الشخص ولكن ايضا في جانب الاستشفاء اذا
الشخص ما قاعد ياخذ جوده نوم عاليه ما راح
يصير في استشفاء تام وهذا المدخل احنا
ندخل منه من خلال التنفس فكل ما زادت جوده
النوم فيما تنفسي صار او كل ماستر افضل
زادت جوده النوم ويصير حلقه جهاز العصبي
يرتاح اكثر واكثر
مثلا اذا سويت تمرين الصندوق
يعني ياخذ ممكن كم يوم ويصير نومي باني ما
اقدر اتحكم بنفسي
فهذه يساعد اكيد
من يعني في في تجارب عديده جدا من تطبيق
واحد فقط
جهازك العصبي دقات قلبك وتيره التنفس
العصب الحار يشتغل وتدش بنوم اعمق وهذا
التجربه من يوم واحد فقط ممارسه مره واحده
ايه دايما الناس ما تفهم اهميه هذا
الموضوع الا لما تجربها اما تجرب وتحس
بالفرق هنا راح تلاقي جوده النوم اعلى
وانت تقعد تقوم فريش مو المفروض عبد
الرحمن يقوم من النوم وانت متكسر انا نايم
ليش متكسر
والمفروض تقوم من النوم
يحسن من صوتهم اوكي لاحظ كارل انه لما
نحسن من الصوت النفس يتحسن
وانشهر بهذا الموضوع في نيويورك وعلى اثره
كان عزتها في مرضى انفزيمه ام فيزيمه مرضي
وحوش الرئتين وخلاص ما له حل
وظيفه عيدها للرئتين ما لها حل بس قالوا
يحسن من التنفس غريب نشوف شو يسوي
المستشفى قالوا لنا بيك تشتغل على هذه
المرضى هذه المرضى طبعا
نايمين ما يقدرون يصعدون الدرج اعدات
قليله
ياخذونها في اليوم ما ياكلون لان في مشكله
التنفس فانا اخاف انه يصير في شيء لما اكل
اختنق فصحتهم جدا سيئه فلاحظ كاستاو اول
ما وصل
بانه اغلبهم حاطينهم على ظهورهم وفي مخده
تحت الظهر على اساس ترفع القفص الصدري ظنا
منهم بان الشهيد راح يصير اسهل
اول شيء سوى مشان المخاد وقام يفحص القفص
صدري بايده وهو كان عنده فن اكثر ما هو
علم لان للاسف ما قدر يعلم الا شخص واحد
بعده كان سيء في في ان النقل المعلومه
فالحين باقي وحده بس اذا ماتت خلاص ما في
علم فكان يحط ايدي على القفص صدري ويشوف
شلون يتوسع لاحظ انه اغلب قفص صدري عند
الناس اللي عندهم انفه مرتفع من الامام
فاول شيء سواه شال المخده وقام يركز معاهم
على الزفير
وابتكر طريقه بانه المراجع يقدر يطلع
الزفير بشكل اكبر عن طريق العد وقت الزفير
فالحين لما قاعد اتكلم قاعد طلع زفير بس
اذا انا كررت شيء بشكل متواصل هنا راح
اقدر اطول الزفير عندي اوكي فقام يقول لهم
عدوا من واحد للعشره بشكل بصوت مهموس ولكن
نفس الوقت مسموع شوي متواصل اوكي فقام
ويطول يطول يطول يطول ويعيدها وعيدها
ويعيدها بعد يمكن شهر شهرين المرضى اللي
قاموا يقومون ويمشون يصعدون وقاموا ياكلون
بشكل اكثر لان التنفس صار افضل
خذ هذا التجربه
طبخها ايضا على الفريق الاولمبي اتوقف 68
مع فريق تراكم في العدائن وهو الفريق
الوحيد اللي ما استخدم اكسجين كلهم
ميداليات لو تذكر في صوره شهيره في
الاولمبيات اللي الفايزين كلهم سمر
ورافعين ايدهم فوق على حركه البلاك بانثر
هذا دربهم على التنفس فالتنفس السمعي هو
استخدام هذه الارقام واحد اثنين ثلاثه
عشره تكرار بشكل مستمر اساس اطول الزفير
كثر ما اقدر لما اطول الزفير عضله الحجاب
الحاجز يصير فيها اطاله من عضله الحجاب
الحاجز تنقبض مع الشهيق فاذا طولت الزفير
يصير فيها اطاله مثل ما سويت فيها اطاله
كل ما صار فيها كفاءه اكثر في الانقباض
فهذا استخدم انا مع
المراجعين على اساس اطول الزفير لما اطول
الزفير ايضا يتفاعل عندي العصب الحائر
اللي هو يامر الجسم في الاسترخ
يفرز مضادات التهاب ويحسن الاتش ار بي
معدل تغير دقات القلب عندي ويحسن من الهضم
يحس من اللعاب كل هذا بسبب النفس ولكن من
خلال العصب الحائر نفسه نعم اذا انا الحين
في وضع خل نقول مشحون مو وقته اهضم طاقتي
لازم تروح لمواجهه هذا الضغط بالطاقه راح
تهدر على
دقات القلب اصلا الهضم خلاص يبطئ وايد لما
اكون
انام فتشوف ارتباط ما بين والله
الاستر الهضم
مشاكل في الخروج لان انا في وضعيه ما هي
مرتاحه فوظائفي وانا مرتاحه ما راح تكون
سليمه
الله يعطيك العافيه الله يعافيك شكرا
جزيلا حياك الله شكرا لكم شكرا
لايمن الحمادي في اعداد الحلقه محمد نور
شمت في التحرير وهاب موسى في التصوير وفي
التسجيل الصوتي عبد العزيز المزي والهندسه
الصوتيه محمد الحسن والتلوين عبد المجيد
العباس وفي اداره محتوى التواصل الاجتماعي
نوره السبيعي وفي اداره التحرير البرنامج
هذا فنجان احد منتجات شركه ثمانيه لنشر
التوزيع نشر كل الانتاج بحب بمدينه الرياض
الاسبوع المقبل القادم
[موسيقى]
في مجتمع عربي فالمفروض انه يكون في محتوى
عربي
بالانجليزي قمت جاوب
فاشكرك على هذه على هذه النقطه جدا جدا
الله يعطيك العافيه الله يسعدك